Guten Morgen genossen ganzen Skandalen und um Amazon Alexa wirst doch irgendwie gut wenn es einen vertrauenswürdigen Sprachassistenten gäbe oder.
Ja so von dem Unternehmen dass es mit mit Datenschutz auch einfach mal ernst meint ja sowieso Facebook z.b.
Ich würde dann so ein Facebook Sprachassistent heißen.
Mark.
Marc lösch dich.
Logbuch Netzpolitik mit der Folge 297 aufgenommen am 19. April 2019 in Wien am.
Herzlich willkommen.
Weißt du was Karfreitag ist.
Oh ja an einem Feiertag eigentlich aber.
Aber trauriger Feiertag oder so ne ich habe mich da heute versucht einzulesen am ehrlich gesagt das muss man auch gar nicht wissen habe ich dennoch nur das ein bisschen wirres Zeug.
Ja also der ARGE hat entschieden dass unsere Feiertagsregelung rechtswidrig ist und die Regierung hat darauf reagiert indem sie einen ganzen Feiertag einfach gestrichen hat Saale ja.
Den hier jetzt und da sind aber die Katholiken doch bestimmt durchgedreht weil ich habe verstanden das ist irgendwie den am wichtigsten dass der wichtigste Feiertag oder so.
Ich muss ich den ich habe da keine Aufmerksamkeit drauf verwendet also ja also jetzt.
Sag es ihrem Konzept was wir beide nicht haha.
Sprechen wir.
Wir feiern wir uns jedes Wochenende Feiertage aber doch nicht.
Ja aber herzlich willkommen in Wien die ist daher kann uns herab.
Er ist halt das traditionelle Osterfeuer des Chaos Computer Clubs und wir schauen mal was da heute noch so passiert du hätte und Vortrag heute Abend noch.
Genau genau wie du mein Nettetal ettenbüttel zusammenräumen was passiert ist und die Reform die dieses Jahr passiert ich glaube es wird sogar noch.
Feuerwehr gibt immer auf deine CCC Veranstaltung ist immer Aufzeichnungen und das wären wir dann wahrscheinlich nicht mehr mit Fahrrad fahren weil ich hoffe dass diese Sendung vorher veröffentlicht wird aber das kann man sich ja dann.
Auf media.ccc de zeitnah finden wer meine Erwartung das Live Event des Jahres 2019 steht ja vor der Tür,
ihr erinnert euch 4. Mai 2019 pünktlich wenn ihr aus der,
Untersuchungshaft nach dem ersten Mal wieder freigelassen werde noch vor der Republica,
im Babylon in Berlin und der Vorverkauf.
Jetzt gestartet während wir sprechen habe ich auf den großen roten Knopf gedrückt und ihr könnt also jetzt Tickets kaufen wir bitten euch da.
Zügig zu tun.
Damit wir den Vorverkauf dann auch schnell beenden können Taschengeld haben um die Vorbereitungen für die Sendung und die Live-Sendung zu.
Und bisher waren unsere Veranstaltung immer ausverkauft insofern lohnt es sich da schnell zuzuschlagen.
Wie immer auch wieder Shirts zu kaufen dieses Mal habe ich mich für eine dezente Variante entschieden wer mich.
Ich nur schwarz trage und deswegen eine,
milde Tendencies immer dazu habe dass es schwarze Klamotten gibt so zu verspielt auch bei dem Kongress Klamotten wo ich mich inzwischen glaube ich auch etwas unbeliebt mache ich das immer schwarz dabei ist werden auch die allen T-Shirt dieses Mal wieder schwarz sein
schwarz auf schwarz ich fahr ich trage schwarz solange bis irgendwas dunkler machen und.
Der wir haben jetzt einen der Aufdruck ist LocoNet fertig.
Schwarz mit ein bisschen Glitzer auf schwarz und zwar ist das die das Druckverfahren oder die der destyle wie wir auch den 34c 3,
dt30c drei Phasenprüfer gedruckt haben auf die Hoodies falls ihr dieses Textil in eurem.
In eurem Biergarten über Skizze.
Blitzer RSH ganz wenig das ist also die die die Menge Glitzer hat damals Gregor Sedlak der ja das Design 10343 gemacht hat noch eigens,
Weimann Druck in der Druckerei ausgewählt ist genauso das man,
nicht genau weiß ob der jetzt Glitzer drin ist oder nicht wenn man DZ ne aber ok der Vater da wir uns entschieden die die die Shirts jetzt geben die gibt es auch schon im Vorverkauf ihr tut euch und unseren gefallen wenn ihr das beim Vorverkauf macht weil dann einfach,
garantierte Shirt hat das kurz bei.
Beim Event abholen könnt gegen QR-Code und alles sehr viel zügiger schöner und besser tickets gibt's wieder in der mehr Klassengesellschaft wir spiegeln natürlich wieder,
das ist Unterschiede gibt.
In all den Einkommensklassen wir haben natürlich wieder die friends Tickets also die die ermäßigten Tickets die so kalkuliert sind dass das,
kostendeckend ist wir haben dann die Standard Ticket die so kalkuliert sind dass wir auch ein bisschen Gewinn machen können mit der Veranstaltung und die haben die Premium Tickets front of stage und Loge.
Loge ist also doch ein altes Kino dann oben.
Vier Looschen auf vier Plätzen wo man also ein bisschen höher sitzt also ein bisschen abgegrenzt vom allgemeinen,
Möbel DDR da auch dort empfangen und da ist ein bisschen über die über den Sachen steht ja das man ist halt.
Dass ich und.
Front of stage II rolling stones abgeguckt wer ganz vorne stehen möchte oder sitzen mit uns gibt's ja Sitzplätze.
Die ersten beiden Reihen sind im Babylon so ein bisschen weiter vorne auch dafür den etwas erhöhten Preis eine.
Eine etwas verbesserte Sitzposition dieses Event.
Ist im Prinzip wie ihr wisst wir machen bei LocoNet bitte keine Werbung wer wird nerven euch nicht mit ewigen Gebettel um Spenden und deswegen machen wir diese Events sie dann doch sehr viel.
Arbeit für uns bedeuten und für diejenigen die wir unterstützen die wir alle angemessen entlohnen möchten.
Dafür dass ihm dazu dass diese Events im auch einen entsprechenden Preis haben und wir hoffen.
Dass ihr euch freut uns da irgendwie auch zu unterstützen diese Gelegenheit nutzt mit uns gemeinsam zu feiern ja Link ist in den Shownotes.
Und es ist wie immer bei unseren Freunden von pritex verkaufen wir die Tickets pritex.de Slash.
Irland Israel mp3.
Und es gibt auch noch die Seite zum Eventlog hoch minus Netzpolitik de Schrägstrich 300/300 aus.
Kult Mofa nicht also ich glaube dass das erste Mal dass ich auf ein Event gehe also ich habe euch haben wir am Congress meine schon gemacht mit Andrea aber ansonsten habe ich alle special events ausgelassen also ich.
Soweit er bei der 150.
Ich habe nicht ne.
Ich war beim Camp mit Julia Reda.
Doch doch doch ja ja gut er hatte in diesem Zelt ich erinner mich ergibt aber diesmal Netzpolitik ins Separee das wird schön.
Bei diesem Bericht genau die hat die Separees hatten wir.
Letztes mal noch mit angeboten deren wir dieses mal rausgelassen ist der die sind quasi hinten ganz hinten hinter einsitzrecht dir zu Kabinen die haben wir diesmal nicht mit in den Verkauf genommen weil ich weiß nicht wie ich fand die nicht so gut,
und dachte mir das bieten wir lieber nicht an und nutzen das was er sich als Erzlager oder dann haben wir Feedback.
Für die letzten Sendungen das wird jetzt ein etwas längerer Feedback Block weil wir viel schönes Feedback bekommen haben dass ich hier würdigen möchte.
Und das erste Feedback kommt von einem Mitarbeiter der Schokolade Schokolade Hersteller Ritter,
zieht sich auf die sendung mit die ich mit Frank gemacht habe über den Ausfall infolge der das sind der Notepad ja Ransomware Schrägstrich destruction O'Hare Angriffe.
Leider ist in Minute 44 ein kleiner Fehler der Rettinger befahl im Jahr 2017 war bei Milka.
Außerdem finde ich es nicht schön wenn wir mit Nestlé in einem Satz genannt werden so.
Das Feedback eines Schokoladen I dass alles anonym gehalten Mitarbeiters des schokoladenfabrikanten Ritter Sport das tut mir natürlich sehr leid.
Ja aber dass die schon allein irgendwelche message control machen unsere Konkurrenz.
Berkenbusch Bumper Schokoladen Quadrate schicken.
Sei vorsichtig was du dir wünschst.
Außerdem haben wir ganz nettes öffentliches Feedback bekommen vom
Netzfilter das hat ein Artikel lies ein Artikel erschienen von Jannis LocoNet Boutique mehr Nerds in die
Politik wohl LocoNet fertig empfohlen und bewertet wird als der perfekte Nachrichtenüberblick zu nat Politik David zeichnen sich Linus und tim durch ein tiefes Wissen,
epische Hintergründe in den einzelnen Themenbereichen auch kein Wunder.
Sind es doch schon seit acht Jahren fast immer die gleichen Schreckgespenster die des Netgear Geistern Vorratsdatenspeicherung Internetzensur Staatstrojaner.
Aber die beiden werden nicht müde das Ganze bis ich zu begleiten.
Dir Dank wir freuen uns immer wenn wir empfohlen werden und freuen uns natürlich auch wenn ihr uns weiter empfiehlt an eure Freundinnen Freunde Hörerin Leserin
und Eltern sind insofern danke für diese schöne lobende Erwähnung.
In der Folge mit frank haben wir.
Außerdem über diesen Straftatbestand geplante Straftatbestand des digitalen Hausfriedensbruchs gesprochen habe ich eine Nachricht von MDR halten der
uns ja auch bekannt ist aus der Sendung über das elektronische anwaltspostfach da war er glaube ich zu.
Meine ich das einzige Mal dass wir in der Sendung hatten aber sicherlich nicht das letzte mal da erwähnt er wichtige Ergänzung.
Die Geschichte zum digitalen Hausfriedensbruch kennst du aber eigentlich auch. War das Frank und ich in der Sendung nämlich gesagt hatten wir wissen nicht genau welche Schutzlücke damit gemeint ist,
und md erwähnt es gab da das Skynet Bordnetz das hat
Bitcoin auf fremden Rechnern gemeint da die mining Software über usenet Downloads verteilt wurde hat die Gruppe keine Zugangsdaten ausgespäht oder Hürden überwunden
die User haben die Software mit Zusatzfunktionen aus dem Usenet selbst geklickt.
Da die meiner nur Bitcoin gemeint haben und keine vorhandenen Daten verändert oder ausgespäht haben sondern nur ihre Software dazu installiert haben.
Ist die hessische Salbei Elite vor dem BGH dem Bundesgerichtshof krachend gescheitert weil es eben keine Datenveränderung gab seitdem sehen sie da eine strafbarkeitslücke,
die eben von Staatsanwalt Mai von ZEIT und Franosch vom Justizministerium geschlossen.
Werden soll also ja offenbar hier echt der Targobank und ich lange gerettet haben was was ist was kann man mit Schatz Software machen die nicht.
In irgendeiner Form was nicht unter die Paragraphen 202 fallen würde die wir heute schon haben findige und Netzbetreibern.
Haben da offenbar Ideen gehabt.
Ja es fühlt sich auf jeden Scheunentor an weil im Grunde geht's ja hier um eine ungewollte Funktionalität die du dir wissentlich oder nicht wissentlich runterholst dabei
was ist ein bewusster Installationsvorgang des Nutzers also einfach das.
Also ich könnte mir vorallem erstmal vorstellen also erstens will ich dazu sagen.
So wie der Text formuliert ist in dem Aldi sicher Gesetz Sicherheitsgesetz 2.0 sehe ich nicht dass er diesen spezifischen Teilbestand abdecken würde zweitens.
Unerwünschte Funktionen nun habe ich auch an meinem Computer eine ganze Menge ja ich habe mich nicht mehr ich mein guck dir diese Telemetrie Funktionen von Windows 10 anfällig ja super wenn das alles unter digitalen Hausfriedensbruch fallen würde,
ich denke also ich finde den den Hintergrund hier den juristischen und historischen Hintergrund sehr spannend.
Ist aber echt nicht wie der wie der Artikel in der Formulierung dem irgendwie gerecht werden würde.
Dann gab es noch eine wichtige Ergänzung von Beate die,
mich darauf hinwies dass nämlich der Betreiber des Darknet Forums Deutschland im Deep Web verurteilt wurde die haben in der letzten Sendung noch darüber spekuliert dass es da ein Verfahren gibt und ich habe.
Sehr gewundert ja wie kann mir das entgangen sein denn eigentlich lese ich ja
alle Nachrichten immer für diese Sendungsverfolgung und bin ein absoluter News Junkie und es gab aber direkt und heiße Link dazu Jahren heiße lese ich auch eigentlich rauf und runter vom 19.12.
2018.
Das ist generell eine Zeit in der ich Kongressmesse ich dann doch mein nachrichtenkonsum ein bisschen runter Schraube und so habe ich das offenbar.
Nicht wahrgenommen oder verpennt oder vielleicht hatten wir sogar in der Sendung und ich bekomme ich noch nicht mal mehr daran erinnern aber vielen Dank für diesen.
Hinweis von Beate ich freue mich immer wenn solche wenn solches Feedback kommt aus der Hörerschaft wo sich zeichnet,
ja wir eben Hörerinnen und Hörer haben die auch weit über das hinausgehen nicht irgendwie nur LMT quasi weitesten Sinne konsumieren sondern eben auch selber in den Themen dran stecken und hier die Ergänzung bringen deswegen ist heute auch der.
Feedback Feedback Block solang ein weiteres Feedback kam von Harry der schreibt
uns oder mir vielmehr schade Dinos dass du den Betrieb eines IT Sicherheitsmanagements wohl als bürokratisches übel einzustufen scheinst in einem mittelgroßen Unternehmen liegt der Umfang anite ESET.
Einige zehntausend Komponenten eine systematische und Schutz bedarfsgerechte Pflege geht in diesen Dimensionen nicht ohne effiziente,
und stringente Prozesse Ziel ist natürlich die Technik und die Sicherstellung einer möglichst Bett einer bestmöglichen security.
Das geht aber nicht auf dem Wege das Admins im freischwebenden Raum herum wursteln somit ist ein wirkungsvolles Management der Weg,
zum Ziel lieber Harry das hast du wahrscheinlich falsch verstanden was ich da gesagt habe denn genau das zu machen und dabei als Consultant zu helfen ist mein Job und zwar nicht nur in mittelständischen Unternehmen sondern in großen
kleinen mittelständischen und sehr großen internationalen Konzernen ich denke nur dass es.
Problematisch ist dass das überhaupt in dieser Form notwendig ist also zwei Punkte die mich die ich.
Verbinde ich als problematisch sehe.
IT und IT Sicherheit werden im Prinzip getrennt behandelt auch in den Unternehmen häufig getrennt abgebildet und das hat gerade bei den kleinen und mittelständischen Unternehmen.
Die fürchterliche Konsequenz dass sie sich vielleicht gerade mal IP leisten können nicht aber IP Sicherheit und das AT Sicherheit überhaupt immer so getrennt überhaupt wahrgenommen und gesehen wird.
Halte ich eigentlich für den Fisch schon mal den Ursprung allen Übels du hast natürlich recht dass das in größeren Infrastrukturen nie ganz in den Griff zu kriegen sein wird aber ich denke wir sind uns auch beide einig dass.
Das Ausmaß in dem Aldi Sicherheit zusätzlich zu IP betrieben werden muss einfach zu groß ist.
Auch schon in in kleineren Unternehmen und das ist quasi in jedem Unternehmen egal wie du es machst nehme ich zu diesen Reibungen kommt zwischen bei Thibaut irgendwas macht irgendwas,
und dann kommt als die Sicherheit und sagt das geht so nicht,
oder man versucht es von vornherein richtig zu machen kommt aber dann nicht vorwärts das überhaupt in IT Sicherheit immer wieder so eine Rolle spielt insbesondere Management von Unternehmen insbesondere bei Unternehmen die nicht unbedingt als hier abhängig sind
Silhouette die IP abhängig sind aber nicht irgendwie eine eine eigene.
Sag mal kein Computerunternehmen er sagt dass ich die im Prinzip.
Den Anspruch haben dürften zu sagen IT wollte genauso kaufen wie,
was hat sich Steuerberatung Fahrzeugflotte oder sowas ja das muss ab und zu mal ab und zu sein Auto kaputt das muss dann in die Werkstatt aber wir können erwarten dass die Autos so funktionieren wie wir sie gekauft haben dass es bei Aldi leider nicht der Fall.
Ja was ist muss halt einfach auch viel mehr wirklich in die Ausbildung oder programmieren Opel Zafira hinten rein und das ist genauso wie mit dem Dart,
kannst Datenschutz auch ganz schwer im Nachhinein dazu Pflanzen über ein fertiges Produkt stülpen das muss schon InDesign in machen
bedacht werden die ganze Zeit,
an der Fils oft eine Ausbildung also eigentlich müssen wir da hinkommen wie das nicht wenn du Architekt bist und ein Haus planst dann machst du nicht irgendwie ganz am Ende wenn das Ding vielleicht zur Hälfte schon steht nimmst du dich um den Brandschutz sondern es muss wirklich schon klar sein das Sinn.
Kannst du machen haben wir auch gemacht in Berlin beim Flughafen mit dem sehr innovativen Brandschutz konz.
Ja wunderbar funktioniert aber ich glaube schon also Zeit der geht einfach um Verschränkung von diesem Grundprinzipien wie man id verantwortungsvoll einsetzt und da kann man nicht zufrieden mit Beginn.
Richtig und man muss sich ja wirklich nur umschauen ich sage das in Vorträgen über das Thema immer gerne
das ist jetzt wirklich also man ist schon klar dass IT Sicherheit jetzt im Moment nicht unbedingt eine Erfolgsgeschichte ist und genau von diesem dass das dass wir in größeren Unternehmen.
Wirklich hunderte Mitarbeiter im Bereich der IT security brauchen ja das kann.
Da würde es auch helfen wenn du es wirklich in die programmierausbildung Andi hatte erst die Informatik studieren mit rein bringst dass du halt einfach weißt wie Animeserie zottegem Siri,
nein wie kann ich irgendwie sicher mit Passwörtern umgehen ja das sind so Dinge die in meiner Ausbildung sicherlich noch keine Rolle gespielt haben aber eigentlich gehört das dahin,
das muss wirklich auf der von der von der Pike auf den Daten mitgegeben werden dann hast du danach auch nicht zuviel
Aufwand irgendwie die Dinge im Nachhinein abzusichern was wahrscheinlich auch teurer ist als wenn du das von vorderen mitdenkst.
Und also also gesagt hast sehr schön mit diesem eine Stelle bevor Architektur würde ohne Brandschutz.
Gelehrte und dann wenn die Leute sein wird werden wir wahrscheinlich immer noch Reetdächer.
Weil immer erst wenn man fertig ist einer käme und sagen würde EU Reetdach ist aber schwierig da müssen wir jetzt noch ein Löschteich nehmen das Haus bauen ja,
öffnen und immer würde nie an dem Punkt kommen Zusagen vielleicht versuchen wir Reetdächer zu reduzieren ja kann ja wer das möchte Didi.
Die Risiko,
affinen Leute kann das ja tun aber es wäre gut wenn unsere Städte nicht ausschließlich mit redlich eingedeckt sind weil das auf Dauer eben nicht gut.
Ein Netzpolitik Fremder aber auch sehr wichtiger Hinweis kommt von max,
weil wir ein bisschen darüber gelächelt haben was die Schrift Sütterlin angeht wenn magst schreibt uns Sütterlin ist eine vereinfachte Form der altdeutschen Kurrentschrift und wurde von Hitler.
Anfang der 40er Jahre verboten die Fraktur übrigens auch.
Es seien judenlettern so damals der Nazi Tenor lesenswert ist dazu der Abschnitt zum normal Normalschrift Erlass im Wikipedia-Artikel zu Antiqua.
Und Fraktur Streit nach dem Krieg fand die Besatzer ist übrigens total super dass nicht mehr die altdeutsche Schreibschrift an den Schulen gelehrt wurde die hätten sie nämlich nicht so gut lesen können so verschwand die altdeutsche Schreibschrift.
Völlig was wirklich schade ist heute kann kaum ein Schüler Dokumente lesen die gerade mal 100 Jahre alt sind.
Er schreibt ja fand ich auch mal einen wichtigen Hinweis der mir in der Form gar nicht unbedingt klaber.
Muss dir auch nie und ich kann das leider auch nicht lesen.
Der Österreicher.
Komplett kulturellen das ist nur Garantie Gerechtigkeit.
Zum Thema Wikileaks haben wir natürlich viele Kommentare bekommen.
Ausführliche Kommentare bekommen lohnt sich da reinzuschauen ich greife jetzt nur ein paar kurze auf die im Prinzip so ein bisschen einmal.
Faktisch relevant sind und einmal unten,
aber emotional relevant sind CallYa kommentiert eure Geschichte startet mit dem vielbeachteten torques von Assange und Dani Domscheit-Berg
Wikileaks Release 1.0 auf dem 26.03 2009 der name dieses Torx ist allerdings irreführend Wikileaks existierte bereits seit 2006 war zu dem Zeitpunkt bereits zweimal auf dem Kongress.
Vertreten ja das hatte ich aber glaube ich auch gewürdigt und sagte dass sie mit dem torque so wirklich das.
Die Wahrnehmung der Welt dann auch wirklich erreicht hatten aber auch da lag ich falsch denn der Tod den ich meinte,
und das sagte ja auch genau ist der vom 25.03 2000
acht der nämlich mit dem Titel der Titel hatte Wikileaks vs the world und das ist der mit dem Inhalt wo es auch um das Bankhaus Julius Bär geht wo es um diese BKA Sachen geht also ja
genau richtig erkannt ich habe den 25.03 Tork gemeint.
Und auch daraus zitiert aber gesagt es wäre der 26. drei Tore hat noch viel mehr kommentiert der Link findet sich in den schon als das sind ebenfalls wichtige und richtige Sachen die ich aber in Anbetracht der Zeit jetzt hier.
Nicht direkt berücksichtige außerdem hat Adele kommentiert auch ausführlich ich würde nur hier kurz sein
Punkt nehmen dass er sagt die
Idee anonymer Einreichung wurde ja auch deutlich früher schon als akute Notwendigkeit diskutiert Frank hat sie z.b. beim 22.03 Vortrag rilostore vorgestellt wo es ist wohl sehr spezifisch
daraufhin also quasi die Risiken von Wikileaks war ja schon auch immer klar also die Mission muss
sicher gestaltet sein will die Veröffentlichung muss resilient sein die Personen werden Angriffen ausgesetzt sein der ist im Prinzip in we lost the war.
Dem Vortrag von Frank und Rob diese Idee sicherlich auch nicht zum ersten Mal in der Form.
Aufgegriffen Wort Link in den shoutout und dann gabs ein Feedback von Tapsi.
Etwas betrübt wie er über Assange redet
und auch hier wieder geredet habt wenn ihr ihn schon nicht mehr lieb habt dann lass ihn doch einfach in Ruhe seine Situation ist wirklich nicht beneidenswert sich dann noch ewig über seinen schwierigen Charakter auszulassen und Witze über ihn zu
was soll das bringen die persönlichen Befindlichkeiten und Animositäten zwischen euch und erforschen finde ich darüber hinaus,
uninteressant tja Taxi da bin ich ein bisschen anderer Ansicht ich glaube aber auch dass du ein bisschen,
über interpretierst wie wir in Logbuch Netzpolitik eigentlich über alle Themen reden nämlich immer mit einem gewissen.
Sarkasmus und Zynismus.
Ganze Geschichte des habe ich auch denke ich in der Folge über das Wikileaks Thema aus an mehreren Stellen auch betont ist natürlich tragisch und im Wikileaks sind aber auf jeden Fall.
Wenn ich das mal so etwas pathetisch sagen darf die Helden meiner meiner Jugend ne die Idee von Wikileaks ist großartig die Ziele sind daher und ich glaube da auch
weiterhin dran aber Kritik muss eben auch geäußert werden damit es beim nächsten Mal besser läuft es ist
tatsächlich eine traurige Geschichte wie das mit Wikileaks weitergegangen ist und das ist
müssen wir eben auch in der Form würdigen dazu gehören eben auch strategische Fehlentscheidung dieser
Plattform wie z.b. ein polyamorösen Egomanen zum Gesicht dieser leaking Plattform weltweit zu machen ja
das muss man vermeiden das geht einfach nicht lange gut solche Probleme sehen wir an mehreren Stellen das ist jetzt auch nicht die erste Person mit einem.
Soll ich mal starken starten Ego die.
Sich in dieser Form seit ich mal starte ein aufsteigender Stern am Himmel ist der dann irgendwann mit mit großen Drama in in Verruf Gerät.
Daraus daraus muss man da muss man drüber nachdenken daraus muss man lernen die die.
Insofern ich finde dass es ist für mich immer noch sehr sehr schmerzhaft das alles zu sehen und das erinnert mich so ein bisschen.
Wie auch andere Generationen auf Dinge zurückblicken
also wenn du dich mit mit ihm die 68ern unterhält werde jetzt was heißt ich auf so eine die Entwicklung Rot-Grün
zurückblicken wie die über Joschka Fischer denken über die Jahre und sagen der war jahrzehntelang
ein eine Identifikationsfigur und ein Held für mich oder auch die wie du dann entwickelt sagen wie sich was was ich,
Ulrike Meinhof oder Gudrun Ensslin entwickelt haben ja wo dann auch quasi.
Gesagt wird na ja da ist dann irgendwann etwas geschehen dass die dass sie irgendwann so weit gegangen sind dass sie der ganzen Idee nur noch geschadet haben.
Und das ist das was bei Julian Assange leider passiert ist und ich denke da müssen wir auch so drüber sprechen das ändert nichts daran dass wir.
Denke ich nach wie vor brennende Verfechter der Idee der Transparenz sind und nach wie vor auf der Suche sind das.
Irgendwie voranzubringen Transparenz in der Gesellschaft voranzubringen da gibt's ganz viele verschiedene Wege und.
Dummerweise ist es so dass die dass die Marke Wikileaks als solche quasi so abgebrannt ist.
Das leider man sagen muss dass der wird auch jetzt nichts mehr draus.
Ja also da muss man muss glaube ich ein paar lernt schon aus aus verstehen aber kann ich definitiv nicht ignorieren dazu.
Hat er noch zu viele relevante Dinge mitgestaltet im
guten dem schlechten und ja hält der Jugend also ich erinnere mich noch an diesen Tag am 26.03 was man erster Kongress war und das war schon eine.
Frage Stimmung in den Saal mit dem damaligen sal1 ist die sich da vorgestellt haben und die Idee
unheimlich spannend und es war auch extrem mutig aber von dem Tag irgendwie nur die Hälfte verstanden hat weil es halt irgendwie ein starken australischen Dialekt hat und nuschelt.
Am aber er hat auf jeden Fall irgendwie Mut bewiesen dass er.
Diese verrückte Idee in die Tat umgesetzt hat er hat halt irgendwo mal den Absprung nicht geschafft also es wäre dem Projekt sehr.
Viel besser ergangen wenn er irgendwann einmal die Konsequenzen gezogen hat und sich daraus genommen hätte und dass das ist schon eine Lehre die man aufziehen kann ab einem gewissen Zeitpunkt können,
Gründer und auch irgendwie leitende Leute von Organisationen aufhören.
Deprexis anfangen zu Schaden an deswegen ist immer wichtig da auch eher auf die Legacy zuschauen.
Ja das beobachtet man bei vielen Organisationen.
Richard Stallman ist zum Beispiel auch wieder so jemand der der extrem große Ideen hatte und mutig war die nach vorne zu tun aber ich glaube die hat
therapiesoftware Fondation heute keinen Gefallen mehr dass er immer da noch so stark involviert ist und ich glaube dass die Ideen mehr
greifen wenn sie nicht immer nur auf eine Person reduziert werden und das ist so eine Lehre die man glaube ich aus
Wiki Lachs aus sourcefile ziehen kann aber unabhängig dazu wir mal zu dem Break steht die Idee wie du sagst ist extrem dicht.
Das da da da glaube ich auch ist genügend Raum offen für neue Plattformen die das wieder mit Leben füllen und J die Glaubwürdigkeit haben am Ende ist ja doch
spiele Journalismus artig von dem was sie was eine erfolgreiche liegen Plattform zulassen.
Bleiben wir noch kurz ein bisschen jetzt mit unserem ersten Thema bei dem bei Wikileaks.
Es hat sich nicht viel getan aber einiges bei unserer Sendung zum Thema Wikileaks war die Verhaftung von Ola bin im Prinzip noch Neuigkeiten sodass wir die noch nicht in Gänze bewerten konnten.
Er wurde verhaftet in Ecuador bei dem.
Oft am Flughafen weil er eine lang geplante Reise nach Japan antreten wollte wo er sich weiterbilden wollte in Kampfkunst.
Und.
Jetzt muss man dazu wissen er spricht kein Spanisch wird jetzt in Ecuador Übungsfall in Ecuador spricht aber eben Schwedisch und Englisch und arbeitete in einem internationalen Kollektiv zusammen.
Jetzt wird er verhaftet festgehalten und erstmal wird eben nicht gesagt was was überhaupt gegen ihn vorliegt im wird glaube ich insgesamt zwei Tage der
Kontakt zu seinen Anwälten verwehrt und so langsam kommt er überhaupt erst Licht in dieser Angelegenheit mit Äquator
ich kann Land wurde verhaftet sein möchte.
Wer ist Olaf Mini.
Tja also ein eigentlich sehr.
Activa Softwareentwickler Inseln in diesem ganzen liberation Tech Umfeld also entwickelt an.
Verschiedenen Softwareprojekten die sich mal im weitesten Sinne in die Richtung,
Verschlüsselung Privatheit und so weiter gehen seitdem Umfeld auf gar keinen Fall ein unbekannt und wird jetzt hier an dieser Stelle eben oder von Ecuador eben irgendwie.
Der Verschwörung mit Wikileaks und Assange beschuldigt Hintergrund in Ecuador ist eben einerseits diese.
Veröffentlichungen die da den.
Die die Präsidentin Familie da betreffen hatten wir ja schon erwähnt und.
Außerdem gibt es sehr hartnäckige Gerüchte dass eben Ecuador werden.
Das ist sehr zeitnah Feld mit eben Zusicherung des International Monetary Fantan Ecuador und das ist alles irgendwie.
Komische Moreno Lenin Moreno sagt dazu die Nassauische habe in der Londoner Botschaft von Ecuador ein Zentrum für Spionage errichten wollen entsprechend sind da wahrscheinlich geht's dann auch in den Vorwürfen.
Dimona Beanie.
Das ist ein hiermit den USA zu Wikileaks Mitbegründer der Beweis der Staatschef selbstverständlich zurück.
Wir haben als CCC und dem internationalen Aufruf zur Freilassung von Ulla Beanie angeschlossen
und ich verfolge das durch diese Vernetzung eben sehr sehr nah wir werden es diesen Fall auch weiterhin sehr genau beobachten
da gibt's nur gerade nicht wirklich zu berichten die Anwälte sind halt jetzt dran dann ihre Pressestatement und jetzt muss man halt gucken was sie denn gegen den vorbringen und wessen er überhaupt beschuldigt wird es ist zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt immer noch nicht so wirklich.
Klar und verständlich und wir sind ja auf jeden.
Dran außerdem in der letzten Sendung haben darüber gesprochen dass es natürlich jetzt schon auf verdächtig,
ist was da jetzt die Amerikaner ausrechnen für diesen.
Virginia Cortina irgendwie ging durch Vorbringen diese Verschwörung zum Eindringen in einen Computer und so alles alles natürlich sehr auf dünnem Eis insbesondere weil er das
erfolglos getan hat sie alles schon irgendwie spannend ja dass sie dann irgendwie so viele Jahre später genau wenn der aus der Botschaft fliegt mit mit diesem aus diesen aus diesem
indightment daher, neben dem Auslieferungsersuchen und,
es ist sehr interessant was dafür die Grundlage ist da gibt's nämlich ein sogenanntes ST David das ist quasi die die Aussage auf der das alles passiert einer FB,
i Agenten Special Agent des FBI seit 2011 die hier eine Summary of several cores.
Beschreibt und quasi sagt okay ich fasse hier mal zusammen warum wir.
Überall soll ich mal über Zweifel erhaben davon ausgehen dass es diese.
Verschwörung gab es indes gibt also einen Chat zwischen einem.
Zwischen zwei Jabber Account einmal von Chelsea Manning Dog network at jabber.ccc.de.
Und einer Person mit den Initialen nf unter dem Account press association.
Jabber.ccc.de und diese Chats wurden wiederhergestellt von Chelsea Mannings Rechner die haben also irgendwie,
waren offenbar in der Lage diese Chatlogs wiederherzustellen Chatlog spielen im Leben von Chelsea Manning eine Navi vor tragische Rolle.
Denn dass Adrian Lamo in der Lage war sie zu verraten ist das war eben quasi auch der. Weil,
ich glaube damals die Software Dilemma benutzt hat war wenn ich nicht täusche Adium der Jabber Client für Mac OS.
Seeteufel Wolfgang und der hatte die hatte zwei derzeitigen zu sagen wenn die wenn der Chat OTR ist loggen wir nicht.
Aber das war per Default aus
und somit wundern quasi nur verschlüsselte Botschaften ausgetauscht und am Ende aber in Plaintext auf die Platte geschrieben und
im spiet in Chelseas Leben irgendwie eine ärgerliche Rolle gab jetzt hab ich keine genaueren Auskünfte darüber wie Sie Ihren Computer gesichert hat wie die in die Lage versetzt wurden diese Chatlogs wiederherzustellen fakt ist
sie waren es außerdem hat sie in ihrer.
Court Martial Anhörung gesagt dass sie davon ausgeht dass die Person mit der sie kommuniziert war hat eine wichtige Person innerhalb von Wikileaks war z.b. Julien RV,
und oder einen Proxy representatives weiterhin
haben sie aber dann genau diese chatte the Jets angeschaut und teilweise gesagt nf daneben.
Gibt also Auskünfte sowas wie ja ich debattiere gerne ich hatte gerade eine bei der EM ma
der Icelandic modern media indiziert hilft und wenn man daneben historisch schaut dann hatte Julien Assange zu dem Zeitpunkt eine und daraus derartige Beispiele aus konstruiert sie daneben.
Die Beschuldigung würden erforsche also quasi sozusagen so ist jetzt eigentlich mit an Sicherheit grenzender Wahrscheinlichkeit dass er es einfach war
so dieses fi David, insgesamt doch schon bisschen dünn Vorwahl gerade dabei ich meine da können ja auch zu unterschiedlichen
Zeitpunkt unterschiedliche Personen dran gehangen haben und insgesamt ist das natürlich also das stinkt halt bis zum Himmel das ausgerechnet die USA ihn jetzt wegen hierdurch versuchen so viel Jahren irgendjemand Angebot nimmt ein Passwort zu cracken Hasselt nicht geschafft
da wo drauf steht in den fünfjährigen Haft oder so.
Dass sie das Ding jetzt ausgerechnet zu dem Zeitpunkt aus dem Hut zaubern denn es gab ja schon früher.
Schwere so Vorwürfe gegen schön also wegen denen das Justizministerium ermittelt hat und wo dann auch z.b. letztes Jahr Daniel daniel Domscheit-Berg.
Gefragt wurde.
Hervis Analysesystem hat im Prinzip des BKA gebeten doch mal den Domscheit-Berg zu fragen ob er nicht mal zu folgenden Fragen Stellung nehmen.
Hatte er dann aber gar nicht los zur.
Aber da ging es aber eben um andere Ermittlungen ja das heißt dass es hier relativ klar dass die Amerikaner natürlich noch viel mehr in der Tasche haben,
und diesen Kritikpunkt der letzten Sendung will ich schon mit aufnehmen dass wir uns dann auf den spezifischen Vorwurf konzentriert haben und.
Er am Rande natürlich erwähnt haben dass wir den in einem ganz anderen Kontexten aber natürlich muss man diesen Kontext auch immer vor Augen behalten selbsterstelltes habe auch glaube ich gesagt das habe ich auch in dem indem Englisch und Deutsch formulierten Statement sccc noch mal betont.
Das in der Auslieferung Julian Assange an die Amerikaner.
Unbedingt zu vermeiden ist und das ist auch habe ich es auch in der letzten Sendung glaube ich gesagt dass da sein persönlicher Charakter der Stich spielt für uns eine Rolle die mit ihm zu tun hatten.
Aber das hat natürlich für diese Strafverfolgung noch gar keine gar keine relevante gar keine Bedeutung und.
Pressefreiheit gilt selbstverständlich auch für Leute die Dinge veröffentlichen die uns nicht gefallen weil Presse fängt da an wo Sachen veröffentlicht werden die irgendjemanden.
Nicht gefallen.
Ja nur kurz noch dazu also ich meine natürlich ist es keine Überraschung
die amerikanische Regierung solche indightment in der Hinterhand hat dass die schon mal
diese Anklageschriften vorbereiten für den Fall dass sie sich dieser Person habhaft werden und wahrscheinlich komplett unabhängig davon welche
Parteien in USA gerade im Weißen Haus sitzt dafür hat das Haus einfach auch zu viele der intelligence agencies und sonstige Leute in den USA vor den Kopf gestoßen die haben kann noch eine Rechnung offen mit ihm
trotzdem ist es sehr spannend ich habe die die die letzte Folge für das debattiert und nicht gehört aber das ist ja hier.
Explizit auch ein A1 Tatbestand ist der eben nicht auf die Pressefreiheit ab zählt,
einer der großen Debatten in den USA also Fall das was er so ausgemacht hat was Wikileaks gemacht hat noch und first amendment rights unter Meinungsfreiheit oder ist das anders zu bewerten und deswegen gehen sie halt auf diesen
alten Computer hacking Tatbestand habe ich aber niedriges Strafmaß hat um,
einfach diese diese Frage zu umschiffen um gar nicht erst irgendwie dann mit der ACLU zu tun zu haben ob das jetzt irgendwie kannst du dir schnell ist verfassungsmäßig ist was sie gerade mit Assange ausführen
an und das ist halt einfach immer noch so mitzubedenken wobei natürlich ich glaube das,
da schon mehr als Einvernahme gemacht werden wird wo sie ihn haben wird denn da schon die Daumenschrauben angezogen und
dass das wird definitiv noch unschön werden sich wäre es auch besser wenn er irgendwie nach Schweden geht und dort irgendwie mal dieser Anschuldigungen mal einfach ausgeräumt werden wenn es gerichtlich geklärt wird
amapa,
ja ich meine das ist dass das wird jetzt so zutiefst politisch und ich sehe auch kein Weg mehr dran vorbei dass man da also ich würde hier nicht mehr auf die unabhängige Justiz kaufen muss ich leider sagen.
Den USA in dem Zusammenhang vollständig vergessen und nett also ganz klar Auslieferung von Thyristoren muss verhindert werden,
an die USA nimmt was diese Sache in Schweden angeht das ist
leider seit jeher eben ein sehr ekliges Thema der gab's dann auch von hier Kommentar Tapsi ja Unschuldsvermutung und so weiter ja ja schon richtig und es war glaube ich auch in der Sendung ausführlich gewürdigt was das eben Haarwasser los ist und es ist natürlich auch
eine sehr perfide Strategie der USA eben diese ganzen verschiedenen indightment zu haben und.
Das ein bisschen so,
scheibchenweise vorzugehen und vor allem erstmal sieben Jahre lang gar nichts zu machen ja die hätten ja sagen können so wir suchen den hier ist alles was dagegen den haben gibt den mal rüber.
Aber das sind natürlich nicht sondern hat gesagt ach Gott das ist eigentlich ganz schön wenn der Spinner sieben Jahre lang in dieser Botschaft hängt
7 Jahre lang immer noch dieser vergewaltigungs Vorwürfe um ihn rum Kreisen das kann man immer wieder schön machen und irgendwann kommen wir dann mal scheibchenweise,
und dann haben wir jetzt wie erstmal unseren Vorwurf hier wegen hacken oder oder Verschwörung zum haking und dann können wir mal gucken dann können die Leute darüber diskutieren und dann irgendwann wird am ausgeliefert und dann kommen wir auf einmal mit achso, hier auch noch
Landesverrat hatte alles nicht gesehen und jetzt machen wir dich jetzt mal was ich am Ende fertig nur so die Strategie.
Ich würd sagen wir machen noch mal eine ganz kurze Pause an dieser.
Werbung
es ist
die Veröffentlichung des Jahres 2019 der Maler Report wurde nun endlich in der ersten Teil zensierten
Auflage veröffentlicht und exklusiv für Hörer von logbuch-netzpolitik gibt es die.
Ocirt Version des PDF jetzt zum Download OCR das bedeutet das PDF ist nicht einfach nur ein Scan im Bildformat sondern ihr könnt in eurem E-Book-Reader eine Volltextsuche machen
bereitgestellt wird euch das ganze von Michael Kreil in seiner Dropbox und den Link findet ihr in den Shownotes bitte nicht vergessen beim Download angeben,
Hashtag logbuch-netzpolitik denn nur dann wissen wir dass die Werbung auch tatsächlich funktioniert hat oder so.
Werbung.
Und damit wären wir auch schon bei den ersten schlechten aktuell Nachrichten uploadfilter am Montag was erlaube.
Ja komm wir nachher
am also es ist nun endgültig passiert EU Gesetzgebung es langsam aber jetzt ist sie auch endlich mal zum Ende gekommen uploadfilter
in der EU urheberrechtsrichtlinie sind beschlossene Sache am 15. April hat auch der Rat der Europäischen Union
diesem Gesetz zugestimmt Deutschland hat dafür gestimmt Österreich auch
und insgesamt haben wir damit eine neue EU-Richtlinie die uploadfilter vorschreibt die
Plattform die älter als drei Jahre sind in die unmittelbare Haftung für die Inhalte und Urheberrechtsverletzungen ihrer Nutzerinnen und Nutzer,
Frank tamta dieses Gesetz wird ja zum Amtsblatt der EU veröffentlicht die zwei Jahre Umsetzungsfrist laufen,
Feierabend Mitgliedstaaten Zeit dieses Gesetz
umzusetzen weiß ich mitgestalten wie Deutschland haben schon angekündigt dass jetzt er mal warten bis die EU-Kommission ihre guidelines veröffentlicht das sind nicht bindende auslegungs Details reden Gesetz
gerade eben bei Upload filtern noch recht spannend werden weil Sie wahrscheinlich auch recht technisch werden
also das ist ein Dokument was man sich vielleicht anschauen soll wenn man bei dem Thema aktuell.
Am Laufenden bleiben will ja aber andere Länder von Frankreich haben schon angekündigt dass sie da nicht warten werden auf guidelines die EU-Kommission sondern so schnell wie möglich in die Umsetzung.
Frankreich hat schon seit einiger Zeit irgendwie eine Debatte über neues Urheberrechtsgesetz damit haben sie jetzt nämlich nur gewartet bis diese EU-Richtlinie
fertig ist und wir können uns in Frankreich auf eine besonders harte Umsetzung gespannt machen also Frankreich
da sicherlich ihr die die die drakonische Reformen von filtern und von Haftung vorschreiben man kann sich da auch keine Ausnahmen für Startups erwarten an dieser Stelle.
Das ist das nicht mal auch verstehen weil in Frankreich hat auch dabei die Grüne Partei ist die einzige die so ein bisschen WAG
bei diesem Thema aber alle anderen sind eigentlich auf der von unserer Seite her diametral gegensätzlichen Positionen und und und wollen eine besondere Verschärfung des Urheberrechts das ist Frühstück
die Partei von macron oder for national und deswegen habe ich da wenig Hoffnung und das ist insofern,
relevant weil jetzt jetzt müssen wir uns auch mal ein paar Fragen stellen die wir davor in der Gesetzgebung nicht wirklich viel diskutiert haben nämlich was ist denn der Türgriffe Costco von seiner Umsetzung,
uploadfilter also trifft nicht die französische Umsetzungen
dieses Gesetzes nur wenn ich irgendwie mein Startup meine Plattform aus Frankreich heraus betreibe oder.
In Frankreich ansässige urheberrechtlich geschützte Inhalte oder Urheberin geht am die wahrscheinlichste les artistes
dass mich dieses Gesetz betrifft sobald ich meine Plattform in Frankreich zugänglich mache also sobald ich.
Mit meiner platform.sh das jetzt Vimeo YouTube oder.
Doch nie der ccc.de in Frankreich erreichbar bin falle ich unter dieses französische.
Urheberrechtsgesetz am ähnlich wie wird das ja bei den Betreuern Download Canon
dass ich wenn ich am diesen Download verfügbar mache wenn ich sozusagen jemanden in diesem Land diesen Lady Gaga Song über BitTorrent auch uploade habe ich ja auch eine verfügbar machen in diesem Land vollzogen
am Tachometer noch irgendwie die Abmahnungen dazu bei Privatpersonen die er die nationale Geschichte sind aber meine jetzige Lesertests gesetzeswert dass ich als Plattform
die Frankreich nicht als Gesamtes Land geoblocked dort dann auch schon in die Haftung.
Und das ist insofern relevant weil damit auch alle Ideen für nationale Schranken und Sicherheitsnetze die lokale KMUs und Startups schützen sollen vor diesem Gesetz,
hinfällig sein.
Weil ich dann einfach in Frankreich verklagt werden kann wegen einer Urheberrechtsverletzung die ich in Frankreich begangen habe und da ist kommpet Wurst nach meiner Lesart,
wie ich in Vienna etwaige deutsche Umsetzung dieses Gesetzes Aussee.
Kernproblem würde dafür quasi wenn man wenn Frankreich sagt okay du darfst folgende Inhalte nicht anbieten ok dann machst du halt eine geoblocking Schranke für Frankreich aber die sagen ja du musst.
Upload filtern welche Inhalte du an zeigst und du haftest dafür sofort das heißt YouTube hätte jetzt Probleme zu sagen folgende uploadfilter für Frankreich,
weil es muss aber im Upload passieren und nicht bei der zugänglich.
Da ist da ist das Wort uploadfilter der der falsche Begriff also in Wirklichkeit ist es die verfügbar machen also du kannst schon mit.
Dieser Inhalt ist in deinem Land nicht verfügbar kannst du dich so ein theoretisch draus retten aber das kannst Du halt nicht irgendwie 42728 Urheberrecht Restriktionen in Europa machen.
Es interessiert den Achsel vorher nicht du musst ja etwas sagen was geht immer erkenne den rechtlichen Rahmen gehen.
Genaues technische Umsetzung 7 Grad aber der Stelle ist halt auch so ich ich,
bin nicht ganz sicher aber ich glaube es geht doch nicht so leicht dass du als Dienst innerhalb der EU ein anderes EU Land Geo blockst,
also das könnte auch als Diskriminierung dieses Landes oder seiner Bevölkerung gesehen werden also du kommst da auch innerhalb der EU nicht wirklich,
Dienste im Rest der Welt werden befürchte ich dieses Mittel verwenden und einfach am großen Stinkefinger in Richtung EU zeigen und,
diesen ganzen Kontinent zusehends blocken und das ist eine Segmentierung des Internets,
die wir nur als hochproblematisch im Auge behalten können weil
ja dass das geht ganz weit weg von der Idee eines neutralen offenen grenzenlosen grippalen Internet und gleichzeitig
ist es aber an der Stelle verständlich für viele Dienste die so einer Technologie nicht einführen wollen Sie sich vielleicht noch nicht leisten können und mit diesem Haftungsrisiko sonst nicht umgehen können und das ist jetzt zusehends die Welt in
die wir uns begeben werden.
Für Mainz alles füttern Wald YouTube geben mit EU am Anfang,
die hat gerade noch mal über kleinere Plattform gesprochen die Bundesregierung ist nach wie vor davon überzeugt dass er mit diesem Gesetz nur die.
Gemein sind also die.
Markt mächtigen Plattformen die massenhafte Upload ermöglichen und damit Geld verdienen ja das steht nur leider so nicht in dem Text und es gibt aber eine
immerhin er sagt dann hätte ich ganz stark eine Erklärung zu Protokoll gegeben und dass sie also sagen.
Der Artikel 17 sei zu den neu der Artikel 17 sei von dem Geist getragen uploadfilter nach Möglichkeit zu verhindern.
Hat Deutschland mal wirklich klare Kante gezeigt das ist wirklich eine
tolle eine tolle Nummer für etwas zustimmen und dann halt irgendwelche komischen Erklärungen zu Protokoll zu geben die eben den.
Inhalt dessen was man da ab stimmt eben einfach nicht wirklich treffen.
Ja also diese Zusatz Erklärungen zu Abstimmungen im Rat sind auch also die Kamera auf Klopapier drucken die haben keinerlei rechtliche Bindung,
an wir haben da auch schon Fälle gesehen der Vergangenheit die,
e-privacy-richtlinie war auch sehr umstritten im Rat da gab es auch ein solches begleitprotokoll was mit der Abstimmung angenommen wurde,
wir haben da auch gesehen durch die Rechtsprechung der Höchstgerichte dass diese Erklärung absolut wertlos ist
was zählt sind die Artikel des Gesetzes und in dem Fall wessen richtige ist die nationale Umsetzung,
aber man kann sich da keinen zusätzlichen Spielraum verschaffen es wäre natürlich auch unten,
badisch wenn du am Ende eines Gesetzgebungsprozess ist dann ein Teil der EU an dem Fall der Rat die Mitgliedstaaten noch mal unilateral ein sei,
also das ist rein logisch nicht vorgesehen und macht auch keinen Sinn das sind alles nur politische Willensbekundungen,
am aber ja was tun wir jetzt damit es gibt im Grunde drei Möglichkeiten dieses Gesetz jetzt weg zu.
Der klassische Weg ist zu warten bis das Gesetz umgesetzt ist und dann dagegen zu klagen,
das heißt ich habe eine nationale Umsetzung dieser eu-urheberrechtsrichtlinie und Klage dann dagegen so wird es bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung gemacht haben
das bedeutet ich gehe her und finde mir eine Person die unmittelbaren ihren Grundrechten eingeschränkt ist dadurch und dann kann man an der Clarks Weg bestreiten da gibt's natürlich verschiedene Grundrechte auf die man diese Klage,
aufbauen kann essen auf jeden Fall auch Firmen hier Plattformen hier gefragt weil die natürlich auch in ihrem,
Grundrecht auf,
Geschäfts Freiheit eingeschränkt sind dann gibt's natürlich die Meinungsfreiheit die betroffen ist es gibt den Datenschutz der betroffen ist es gibt,
auch eine eine gewisses Bestimmtheitsgebot von Gesetzen zu müssen Österreich gibt's was ich glaube auch ich hoffe auf die Urheber der auch also das geht jetzt eigentlich konkret und bestimmt sein müssen,
ah ja aber ja also der Weg über einen idual Antrag auch wenn man nicht durch alle Instanzen gehen muss sondern direkt zum
nationalen Höchstgericht das dann,
beweisen kann diese Klage an den Europäischen Gerichtshof reden wir davon mehreren Jahren die es bräuchte um so einen Clarks Weg wirklich durchzubringen und das ist Zeit die wir im Zweifelsfall.
Haben Sie Zeit in der uploadfilter eine Realität werden wie bei jeder gefahren Technologien das kennen wir aus dem Datenschutz zu viel Macht weckt Begehrlichkeiten wenn dieser Filter einmal installiert ist wird,
seine Funktionsweise ausgeweitet dann werden wir auch Filter sehen.
Für andere Dinge bekommen noch zu Tara Verordnung Lara und um das zu verhindern ist es notwendig dieses Gesetz so schnell wie möglich rechtsstaatlich vom Höchstgericht Prüfung zulassen,
und deswegen gibt's noch der andere Wege wie man da vorgehen kann an der.
An zweit schnellste Weg wäre es eigentlich dass wir nach der Wahl nach der Europawahl könnte das Europaparlament mit einer einfachen Resolution im Plenum.
Dieses Gesetz vor den Auge haben eine sogenannte abstrakte Normenkontrolle.
Dadurch hätte der euer Gehalt direkt vom Europaparlament den Prüfauftrag bekommen diese EU urheberrechtsrichtlinie nach gewissen Fragen die das Parlament stellt,
zu prüfen ob es denn verfassungsmäßig ist da müssen wir die Wahl abwarten das hängt ganz stark von den Mehrheiten zusammen von dem erhalten ab
die nach der EU-Wahl dann auch wirklich vorhanden sind und natürlich auch vom politischen Willen an dieser Stelle das ist aber ein Thema
sehr schön bei der Europawahl.
Doch als wahlprüfstein für die hart und Frauen Europaabgeordneten die Kandidatinnen dran ziehen kann um deren.
Netzpolitische Positionierung abzuschätzen um einfach zu sehen okay wie ernst meint ihr es mit dem freien Internet seid ihr bereit dieses Gesetz
vermisst Gericht prüfen zu lassen
ein hervorster glaub da ist alles in Ordnung mit dieser urheberrechtsrichtlinie der sich auch ja sicherlich nicht schmiert für dieses Gesetz ja müsste eigentlich
so einem Antrag zustimmen weil alles was man damit tut ist es prüfen zu lassen von der einzigen Institution die darüber entscheiden kann ob es verfassungsmäßige ist eigentlich sollten auch die Leute die immer.
Anta deswegen wenn man jetzt in der EU weil die Möglichkeit hat Kandidaten zu fragen sollte man diese Frage stellen wie halten Sie es mit einer etwaigen Prüfung der Uwe rechts richtige durch den Orca
1 III Option die aller schnellste wäre wenn ein EU Mitgliedstaat,
dieses Gesetz direkt zu morgen haben in Voerde also wenn ein Mitgliedstaat sich entscheidet das Gesetz nicht
umzusetzen sondern am direkt wirklich eine eine Vorlage zum Auge haben macht da mit A und da
wir haben wir wirklich in Nullkommanix Haare braucht man nicht bei die Wahl abwarten haben es gibt auch da einen bayrisch
spiel Fall den wir verlinken werden wo das Weinland was gegen eine auch in einen einen eingesetzte geistigen Bereich das eben einen an intellectual property auf Lebewesen vorgesehen hatte und das wurde auch von einem.
Zum RGH gebracht der hat ja damit geschafft hat verloren dort,
aber es ist glaube ich aufgrund dieses Beispiel verlässt.
Absehbar dass eben der wirkliche Grund rechtliche Bedenken von einem Mitgliedstaat vorgebracht werden können und werde weniger ist es derselbe Weg wie manche wählen muss.
Ganz ehrlich muss ich aber gerade hier am Karfreitag sagen ne das geistige Eigentum das geistige Eigentum an Lebewesen kann man der Kirche nicht nehmen.
Ich gehe noch zu verantwortungsvoll damit um die Vielfalt dieser Welt gab die Schöpfung
das heißt da da stehen wir jetzt kontrup das nur mal vor mal irgendwie, aufgeschlüsselt die die Option die die formale auf dem Tisch liegen
vielleicht können wir dazu ja auch noch spannende.
Von von vielleicht doch juristisch ausgebildeten hören und hören das wird mich auch interessieren was ihr dazu denkt und.
Auf jeden Fall einiges an Arbeit zu tun wohl bisschen Tabak sagt gerade irgendwie dabei ist sich zu vernetzen und gut aufzustellen grüßt viele dieser Wege in Angriff,
kommen wir zu dem nächsten Thema mit uploadfilter aber positive Nachrichten so ziemlich.
Gute Nachrichten für den Upload filtern mach mir nicht fertig.
Also es ist ja jetzt gerade diese Woche das letzte Plenum des Europaparlaments vonstatten gegangen in Straßburg damit ist diese Legislaturperiode auch durch.
Eines der Gesetze die dort noch übers Fließband gehüpft sind ist die Terror Verordnung
eine Verordnung die sich um die Verbreitung terroristischer und extremistischer Inhalte im Internet kümmert und die in ihrer Ursprungsfassung auch uploadfilter vorgesehen hatte und diese sind jetzt
rausgestrichen worden.
Wir wissen ja dass Urheberrechtsverletzungen schlimmer sind als Terroristen.
Ja das war auch so ein Argument was ich gemacht habe es gab nämlich schon früher in dieser Legislatur Legislaturperiode Dandies rauskriegt einer terra Richtlinie über die das Europaparlament abgestimmt.
Wie zu terrorisieren sei Richtlinie.
Genau es nur nur der hat Oettinger auch mitgeschrieben dieses Gesetz wurde von
wiesen Abgeordneten in dieser Legislaturperiode auch eben beschlossen die richtige App und damals hat die Kommission auch schon probiert uploadfilter da rein zu schreiben und dieses Parlament hat
die rausgestrichen das habe ich das Argument in Busse immer gebracht bei den abklären ihr habt schon mal
ja alle diese Kohorte dazu entschieden dass da wo Menschen sterben es nicht verhältnismäßige ist das Internet zu fehlt dann vielleicht hat er mir das jetzt bei Urheberrechtsverletzungen auch nicht tun,
am Hut hat wie du wissen leider nicht dazu geführt ist für die vielen fünf Stimmen bekommen aber das Argument habe ich gebracht es hat doch glaube ich einige Leute mit denen ich Meetings habe,
zum Nachdenken gebracht haben wir's jetzt wieder geschafft Heere Verordnung,
nicht die richtigen netten Natterer Verordnung sind die uploadfilter rausgestrichen worden insgesamt ist das ein ganz guter Text.
Einen Schönheitsfehler gibt es
wenn Meldungen von am Verfolgungswahn demfall Farm Europol an Provider kommen mit ihr habt ihr terroristische Inhalte löscht die bitte dann müssen Provider innerhalb einer Stunde,
dieser Inhalte vom Netz nehmen und innerhalb einer Stunde twentyfourseven Leute bereitstehen zu haben die diese Inhalte löschen,
das ist schon recht großer Aufwand
da braucht man Journaldienst dieses Gesetz gilt aber nicht nur für Google und Facebook und die großen und Hetzner sondern für jeden einzelnen f****** Poster.
Diesen Kontinent also auch keine Uhr keine Startup mit 12 Personen Betrieb,
ja oder ein Community Projekt es fallen alle unter dieser Terror Verordnung und alle haben jetzt eben diese 1 Stunden Frist einzuhalten was halt dann doch vielleicht auf einen.
Ama automatisierte Lösung hinauslaufen wird nur wir reden hier eben nicht von einem
notice on stay down sondern von einem notice and Takedown das heißt auch voll meldet diese Inhalte bitte löschen und,
ein etwaiger neuer Upload diese selben Inhalt muss dann noch mal gemeldet werden der muss nicht von der Plattform selber schon vom Upload Force veröffentlicht wird,
abgesperrt werden das ist der Unterschied an der Stelle und dazu jetzt auch noch mal wenn man sich denkt occasion Europol wieso dürfen die irgendwie solche Meldungen raus,
die werden doch sicherlich absolut verantwortungsvoll damit umgehen und uns sicherlich nie irgendwie Dinge melden,
terroristische Inhalte sind ja da hat archiv.org gerade entschieden Blogpost veröffentlicht wo sie irgendwie 150 soll solche Europol Meldungen mal ausgewertet haben und darunter auch ganz viele Meldungen,
absolute geilen Inhalten teilweise
großes gab es zu Karin halte die amerikanischen Regierung die Europol für Tourismus hält es lustig und auch Nachrichteninhalte die angeblich Terrorismus sind und archiv.org hat hier irgendwie
paar Sachen öffentlich gemacht.
Du hast dran zweifeln dass und daß Europol mit dieser Macht die Ihnen mit diesem Gesetz noch zusätzlich gebracht wird verantwortungsvoll umgeht.
H&M in gewisser Weise ist es aber schon mal irgendwie ein Fortschritt weil wenn bisher solche notice an tickdown requests kommen,
die häufigste Form in der die daher kommen ist nicht ich habe hier einen Inhalt getroffen gefunden auf deiner pappform und ich glaube dir strafbar nach Paragraph XY sondern
schau mal dieser Inhalt der verstehst doch sicherlich gegen deine AGB also es ist nur eine Prüfung nach den Geschäftsbeziehungen
der Plattform und eben nicht wirklich ein illegaler Inhalt der aufgrund irgendeiner rechtlichen Grundlage es weggenommen werden sollte das ist auch eben gerade das was wir meinen wenn wir davor warnen
dass die Rechtsdurchsetzung und Rechtsprechung zusehends privatisiert.
Jetzt ist das natürlich schon so ein bisschen so ein Thema gewesen mit diesen Christchurch.
Das war natürlich jetzt ein bisschen auf der der Blaupause Fall wo sich auch zeigte ich meine das Video was da kursierte war.
Heftig das musste auf jeden Fall von jeder Plattform.
Verschwinden der sein aber wirklich eifrig die Menschen dabei das immer wieder hochzuladen das gehörte ja zu der Strategie des Attentäters
andererseits aber jetzt auch wieder schöne Beispiele von Terror filtern aktuell.
Gab es ja einen Brand in der französischen Kathedrale Notre dam.
Und die Aufzeichnungen davon wurden von YouTube von Youtubes erkennungs Algorithmus sehr gerne mal gelöscht weil es für Aufnahmen von nine-eleven gehalten wurden.
Ich weiß nicht ob dann das Objekt gelöscht wurde wegen Copyright oder wegen Terrorgefahr.
Wir sehen da wirklich in kurzer Zeit eben zwei Fälle die.
Die Schwierigkeit dieses Themas irgendwie auch illustrieren ich denke notice Takedown und so weiter das bleibt hier dann doch der Klügere weg und auch die Christchurch Videos.
Oder das Christchurch Video wurde ja irgendwie also wurde geteilt.
Von Menschen die irgendwie meinten das andere noch irgendwie zu gehen nicht machen zu müssen.
Ja und es ist halt.
Am Ende immer von kontextabhängig wenn irgendwie LG aus wie wird nass oder Amnesty dieses Video teilen würden und das in einen Kontext stellen dann wäre das einen an ein Gehalt den du nicht vom Netz nehmen
ist bei der vielleicht aufklären oder oder oder erzieherische ist das ist ja das Grundproblem dieser diese Plattform Regulierungsfragen so
schwierig ist und ich finde auch intellektuell so so herausfordernd weil das ist irgendwie alle Fragen unsere Gesellschaft wo wir uns streiten und uneinig sind und darf man das noch sagen und wer sieht hier verantwortlich und wie könnt ihr denn überhaupt all diese Fragen in.
Topf geworfen umgerührt an der genau du bitte globales Unternehmen dessen Geld verdienen will Lösungs das hier.
Löse das mit dem Computer bitte aber sonst könnte auch alles hinkriegen mit eurem Computer und ihr Können rückwärts einparken dann können wir wohl mal eben hier die gesamte gesellschaftliche Debatte um aufgeklärten Umgang mit
Terror klären ja mach das mal bitte kurz ab da sonst auch alles hin bevor wir uns da jetzt drin verlieren.
Würde ich das nächste Thema.
Schneiden ja denn es gibt ja nicht nur von der EU gute und schlechte Nachrichten sondern auch aus Österreich.
Ja also irgendwie haben einige Österreich jemand zu vermelden nachdem wir gerade auch bei den Bienen sind.
Was hat die Schwarzbart Bundesregierung gerade vor.
Punkteins es gibt ein neues Gesetz zu digitalsteuer Österreich will ein Gesetz machen um
Werbeumsätze innerhalb von Österreich zu besteuern das ist ansich keine schlechte Idee es gibt nämlich in Österreich schon eine Steuer auf Werbung in
gedruckten Zeitungen in Radio und Fernsehen nur auf Online Werbung gibt es keine Steuer was
ich finde eine unnötige Bevorteilung es war gerade online Werbung ist ja die die besonders schädlich ist zumindest für unsere Privatsphäre und nach diesem Gesetz soll jetzt eben auf alle in
Österreich oder mit österreichischen
Menschen denen was angezeigt wird blockierte Onlinewerbung an Steuersatz von 5% angehoben werden und davon erhofft man sich ca 15 Millionen an Mehreinnahmen das jetzt eigentlich nicht.
Zu wenig oder.
Und auf jeden Fall gilt dieses Gesetz auch nur für Firmen die mindestens einen globalen Umsatz von 57 Millionen Euro im Jahr haben und einen nationalen Umsatz von mindestens 25 Millionen
also mehr weniger Laggs Facebook Likes Google
weil sonst gibt's das niemanden der so groß ist soweit so unkritisch in gewisser Weise das Problem ist also diese Steuer wird schon beim Anzeigenwerbung fällig und wenn der Nutzer dann damit interagiert.
Das wird teuer ist ein Google mehr wenn die Leute auf dich drauf klicken auf die Werbung Abend dann wird natürlich von diesem Ehrenabend auch noch mal die 5% fällig und um all das zu berechnen und auch zu sagen hey ist das jetzt eigentlich eine Werbung die in Österreich
angezeigt wird in einem auf einem österreichischen smartphonefan österreichischen Webseite.
Ich ahne ist die Steuerprüfung kommt ruhig.
Und über einen Verweis auf die Bundesabgabenordnung wird mit diesem Gesetz eine siebenjährige Vorratsdatenspeicherung von IP-Adressen und Geo Standortdaten mit vorgeschlagen am und.
Oje.
Ja kurz zu erklären also.
Was hat die Steuerprüfung hier für uns getan.
Ja der wie ist noch mal so der Tod und die Steuer,
den entkommst du nicht dieses dieses schöne Gesetz gegen halt wirklich so ein Begutachtung mit dieser siebenjährigen Vorratsdatenspeicherung und zudem Zeit,
war ich gerade auf der AIDA Generalversammlung in London und Max Schrems war auch,
weil da einfach einen neuen Ordner für Business ist ja auch edle member
und wir haben dann irgendwie sind im Kaffeehaus gesessen auf einem bekommen Max einen Anruf von der Abfahrt der österreichische Presseagentur und die haben halt irgendwie die fünf Minuten mit ihm telefoniert
passt
Landi Regio es ist doch aber voll dumm wieso mache das wieso anonymisieren die das nicht also das könnte man doch ja einfach irgendwie letzten Stellen der IP-Adresse oder die letzten menü
Sekunden der Geodaten wegschmeißen dann weiß man immer noch es ist Österreich aber nicht mehr wo genau aber ich muss jetzt wirklich weiter ich habe das Gesetz nicht gelesen keine Ahnung,
aber ja also finde ich irgendwie schlecht liegt auf upper,
Nachrichtenagentur veröffentlicht irgendwie Datenschützer Max Schrems Vorrat bei digitalsteuer könnte man doch anonymisieren,
große Headline ging durch die Medien wenige Stunden später Finanzministerium geil coole Idee das machen wir jetzt so.
Sofort irgendwie von ihrem offiziellen Begutachtungsentwurf abgewichen oder angesagt ja ja so dürfen wir dieses Problem.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt hatte sie schon die Internetwirtschaft beschwert und gesagt so oh mein Gott ich könnt in Orts und ja,
zeigt sehr gut wie durchdacht österreichische Gesetze sind aber wenn es darum geht irgendwie auf den Datenschutz Rücksicht zu nehmen weil das ist einfach nur
ja Datenschutz wanna one wir haben vor darüber gesprochen inventursysteme Designs denkst du Datenschutz mit dann brennt Dir das Reetdach nicht ab
und das hat man ja offensichtlich nicht getan und dir,
befinden uns jetzt immer noch eben Begutachtungsprozess für dieses Gesetz seiner digitalsteuer und es ist spannend wie Sau.
Die Begutachtung läuft noch bis zum 9. Mai und wir einen selber auch mit einer Stellungnahme als epicenter works da einbringen und es gibt sicherlich auch noch andere.
Dinge kritisch zu reflektieren bevor das ein gutes Gesetz ist aber wir schauen uns.
Wir hatten den digitalen Ausweis zwangen auch schon angesprochen aber da habe ich auch schon in Aussicht gestellt dass er dich dann noch mal zu fragen.
Was ist da jetzt los also Thomas du hast auch eine gewisse Verantwortung für dein Land hier Österreich und das geht so nicht weiter.
Ja der sind wir uns los also ich habe ich übernehme nicht die Sachwalterschaft diese Regierung aber ich bin gerne irgendwie derjenige dir sie auch international ans Kreuz nageln an.
Karfreitag Scherze begleiten diese Sendung wie Jesus die die Löcher die ja irgendwie in seinen Händen hat weil er Nagelreiniger.
Die sind hier so sicher wie das Amen in der Kirche.
Ich freue mich auf die religiös konnotierten Kommentar.
Wer ich glaube nicht dass wir religiöse höhere haben.
Jetzt finde ich rausfinden
gut aber nicht das Gesetz also das Wochenende dann irgendwie habe ich Montag Dienstag die Woche darauf ein neuer Vorstoß
für einen digitalen Ausweis Zwang hier muss man grob in das letzte Jahr zurückgehen um zu verstehen was die Regierung hier
gemacht hat also es gab Ende 2018 die Ankündigung der österreichischen Bundesregierung jetzt etwas gegen Hass im Netz zu machen was damit begründet war mit irgendwie einem Fall Sigi Maurer worüber wir kapieren,
das auch schon gesprochen haben und da da gab es eben eine Debatte über hat die Netz in Österreich die,
gut ist die wichtiges das ist ein Problem ich glaube es ist nicht nur ein Problem von Hass im Netz sondern hast generell.
Wir in unserer Gesellschaft die haben aber natürlich ist es gerade online besonders für Frauen die sich
mit Meinungen äußern in Debatten zu Wort melden auf besonders schwierig ist und ganz besonders oft Opfer
von Anfall dungen genauso auch
starte mit kuration Hintergrund die sich vielleicht zu am gebackenen Intimbereich in der ganzen Asyldebatte zu Wort melden türlich auch irgendwie Auseinandersetzungen mit
identitären und FPÖ in Österreich und Antifa auch ein großes Thema ist es gibt genügend Gründe eigentlich in diesem Themenfeld aktiv zu werden
deswegen hat die Regierung an einen 5 Punkte Programm,
der erste Punkt ist eine Strafrechts Novelle von dir immer noch nichts gesehen haben die wird aber bald
kommen dem Vernehmen nach das ist nur also da sollen irgendwie Straftatbestände gemacht werden die es so noch nicht gibt für Hass im Netz da ist es insofern spannend weil dafür beauftragt ist Karoline edtstadler
edtstadler.
Ich habe hier schon mal über sie gesprochen sie ist die Richterin die bekannt wurde in Österreich dass sie obwohl sie einen Schuldspruch verlassen hat ist der Staatsanwalt in Berufung gegangen weil ihr
Strafmaß zu weit über Almbar dass er gefordert hat und für vertretbar hält das halt auch beim Schuld Frucht der da soweit gesagt hat das kann so nicht liegen.
Das ist aber.
Die Frau ist gerade dabei im Strafrecht in Österreich eine Novelle zu schreiben das wird sicherlich lustig sie ist auch Listen II für die Europawahl bei der Volkspartei und steht.
Sprech EU-Kommissarin für Österreich zu werden also von der Frau Hartmann.
Das ist ja unglaublich er so dass es jetzt gerade so dem war erzählt im normalen Strafverfahren ist ja der Staatsanwalt ist üblicherweise.
Fordert
natürlich das höchste Strafmaß oder die Staatsanwaltschaft fordert das höchste Strafmaß weil sie davon ausgeht dass,
die Richterin unter Abwägung der Interessen und so weiter im Zweifelsfall drunter bleibt
Google und dann kann man als Staatsanwaltschaft die Aufgabe der Staatsanwaltschaft ist in der Regel natürlich für eine.
Ausgewogene Bestrafungen zu Sorge zu tragen und die in der Rolle der Staatsanwaltschaft wird.
Bedeutet das natürlich das höchste zu fordern was man unter gegebenen Umständen noch fordern kann wenn die Richterin dann mal darüber hinausgeht,
dann kann das der der Staatsanwalt als im Prinzip als besondere Würdigung seiner Arbeit sehen das aber dass der Staatsanwalt sagt
tschuldigung das kann ja nun wirklich nicht sein wie häufig kommt sowas vorher können wir das loswerden.
Ich glaube sie ist die einzige Richterin in der das jemals passiert ist es ich kenne zumindest keinen anderen Fall ist Maxi geben aber sie ist bekannt dafür und das ist so ihr signature move ja also.
Das wäre so wie das wäre so wie wenn
die Deutsche Telekom eine Netzneutralität einsetzt gegen bleeding die du aufeinmal voran gehst und das also entschuldigung das ist ja wohl wirklich Kommunismus im Internet so können wir das Internet.
Ja also.
Die die die die Rollenverteilung ist hier definitiv ein bissl auf also dass das ist. 1 dieses Fünf-Punkte-Plan. 32 langweilig also Beratungsstellen ausbauen definitiv wichtig muss man machen da,
kannst es oft an den Ressourcen das den Leuten wirklich mal eine Anlaufstelle gegeben wird für für Verein Beratung für Opfer und Zeuginnen
am Bewusstseinsbildung sicherlich auch ganz wichtig ich glaube dass man hier ganz viel gewinnen kann und das sind auch einfach extrem unstrittige Punkte die aber sehr wichtig sind und ich glaube nicht dass wir da wirklich einen.
Bitte muss man eigentlich nur machen und mit dem guten Leuten reden damit man die.
Hinbekommt die IV und V. Ist aber wiederum net politisch waren die.
Klarnamenpflicht die jetzt eben gekommen ist und ein
netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz nach deutschem Vorbild netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz ist inzwischen gefallen dafür sind sie scheinbar.
Was zu komplex ist so etwas zu bauen ohne dass es einem wie Deutschland um die Ohren fliegt oder,
vielleicht wartet man da eben auch auf die EU-Reform zu diesem Thema dir nichts resolut Periode kommt aber was das Gesetz ist vorüber wie jetzt gerade reden ist die Klarnamenpflicht und,
Klarnamenpflicht war nicht der offizielle Titel mit denen sind das vorgestellt haben sondern der war digitales Vermummungsverbot.
Verdi und das Gesetz war doch das Gesetz für mehr Verantwortung.
Sicherheit und Verantwortung im Netz svnr ist ein ein Gesetzesentwurf dhmz April
in Begutachtung geschickt wird vom Ministerrat und es ist eben kein ta-na-e-ka namenspflicht dass ich kann weiter mit einem Pseudonym posten aber.
Du musst registriert sein
quasi mit Adresse mit einem mit einem Identifizierungsmerkmal was wo sich die die die die Telefonnummer beispielsweise anbietet weil ihr da ja jetzt eine Registrierung in der Ausweispflicht für SIM-Karten habt nommen.
Genau sim-karten-registrierung gibt es schon wenn du in Österreich eine SIM-Karte da behaupten september ist des Staates der Stichtag also
wenn du dann ab September betreibst musst deine Identität dem Mobilfunker bekannt sein wenn du in österreichischen Handyvertrag hast auch beim Prepaid gilt das und dadurch haben sie sozusagen schon mal irgendwie
die lautet die Telefonnummer besitzen im Möglichkeit die zu identifizieren Abend der.
Plattformbetreiber was wir reden ja hauptsächlich bei dem Gesetz jetzt hier von vorn Betreibern der muss bei jedem neuen BenutzerInnen Account schauen wer es wirklich die
Person dahinter und diese Daten speichern und auf Anfrage dann hin ausgeben da gibt es natürlich aber dann einige Details also.
Also ich wir hatten das ja wären das in der letzten oder vorletzten Sendung ja schon angesprochen das Problem die Frage ist.
Was macht ihr jetzt so wie die dieses irgendwie die wie diese Identifizierung erfolgen soll ist ja nicht so wirklich klar also diese sim-karten-registrierung habe ich nämlich nicht wirklich daraus gelesen also das haben sie glaube.
Technologie neutral formuliert.
Genaues technologieneutral formuliert dann ist ja auch so ein bisschen so ja ihr könnt.
Die Daten müssen gelöscht werden aber bei Zweifel an der Identität müssen sie wieder erzwungen werden und also alles sehr komisch am Ende steht.
Ja tatsächlich das Ende der pseudonymität im Internet hören dass sie sind ja sehr sie sagen ja.
Pseudonym darf.
Und nach außen genau du kannst nach außen pseudonymität verwende.
Aber es muss wir wollen als Staat zumindest die Möglichkeit haben wenn es uns darauf ankommt.
Dieses Pseudonym Lüften zu können und das betrachte ich als eigentlich das Ende der pseudonymität im Internet wenn ich ehrlich sein.
Das auf jeden Fall ein chilling effect also Leute die vielleicht das guten Grund etwas zu verbergen haben weil sie eine Minderheit angehört weil sie vielleicht noch auf ihren Asylbescheid warten Aldi werden
sich weniger oft zu Wort melden aber das Gesetz ist auch so geschrieben dass es in Wirklichkeit.
Noch viel mehr Kollateralschäden gibt weil die Strafen für die Plattformbetreiber wenn die einen Nutzer mal nicht identifizieren können sind 500000 € bis 1000000 profile.
Ist es wirtschaftlich aufpasst nicht darstellbar irgendwie noch im Forum zu betreiben durch die politischen Hintergründe wissen wir dass der Hauptziel dieses Gesetzes ist es das Forum der größten österreichischen Tageszeitung der Standard,
abzudrehen
am also das wird auch im Standard ganz klar so gesehen so schon seit Monaten im Gespräch und die wollen halt einfach diese Community die das dann das hier hat abdrehen weil das im Moment hat natürlich auch ein großes ß ist wenn weite viel
Interaktion auf der Website haben hier geht doch darum demokratischer Diskurs Räume abzutreten auch die große hat ein Forum was ihr drunter fahren würde eine,
die Bildzeitung ist der Reis aber auch er zur Elternforen würden darunter fallen wenn Sie mindestens 100.000 zerrinnen im Monat oder 500000 Umsatz im Jahr haben oder 50000 Euro Presseförderung bekommen
am das heißt wir hier auch runterfällt ist Facebook die müssten auch so einer Klarnamenpflicht einführen was bedeutet.
Was wir haben.
Ja aber mit wirklich Identitätsnachweis noch mehr Daten für Facebook.
Das einzige was nicht runterfällt ist wie heißt diese unzensuriert.at.
Ja wobei die schon ihr vorm abgeschalten haben weil sie nicht Zitat als Scheinargument von linken Aktivisten verwendet werden wollen,
ja also aber natürlich also das grundlegende Problem ist einfach das.
Anonymität und arschlochverhalten im Internet nicht wirklich viel miteinander zu tun haben.
Die größten die größten a********** kennen wir Namen.
Und Hass im Netz wird durch dieses Gesetz nicht eingedämmt nicht reduziert viele der bekanntesten.
Opfer reden von Hass im Netz sind auch gerade Kritiker dieses Gesetzes und fühlen sich missbraucht von der Regierung Sigi Maurer,
harte Kritikerin dieses Gesetz ist also das Ziel was hier erreicht werden soll dafür ist das Gerät absolut untauglich aber die Kollateralschäden sind enorm.
Wir werden einfach wirklich systematisch demokratischer Diskurs Rahmen in diesem Land vernichtet.
Und das Ganze eben noch dazu auf eine extrem Datenschutz
falls ich Art und ja SIM-Karte schöner gut vielleicht kannst du so jemanden identifizieren aber was machst du denn irgendwie mit Ada das nicht deutschen oder italienischen Handynummer,
wenn du dort nicht über den Telekom
weiter an die Identität dieser Person kommst du darfst in der EU nicht gegen andere EU-Bürger diskriminieren aber du darfst es auch nicht anhand aber Trainer Merkmale wieder Ländervorwahl in deiner Mobilfunknummer machen
also das Gesetz ist nicht ausgekühlt sicher du könntest dann sowie Carsharing Dienste dir den Ausweis zeigen lassen aber da habe ich sozialen gehört von 15 € die da jede Identifikation kostet
das ist wirtschaftlich auch nicht darstellbar wenn du das bei jedem Account machen.
Also das ist das ist eine richtig richtig fürchterliche Idee die wie du gerade schon sagst.
Also die Strafen sind unglaublich krass und unglaublich hoch die.
Anforderung ist eigentlich nicht zu leisten ja wie du schon sagst das ich mein weg.
Belastbaren Verfahren es gibt für eine Authentifizierung von Personen über die Ferne ja da hättest Du eben solche Scherze wie
diese videoident die natürlich auch ihre Schwächen haben ne da kannst du natürlich auch einen gefälschten
glänzenden Ausweis hin zeigen es gibt schöne Demonstrationen mit im Prinzip.
Ja live live gerenderten Effekten ja das also die die Sicherheit dieses Verfahrens in Anführungszeichen basiert ja darauf dass du eine Anweisung kriegst wie du den Ausweis bewegen musst,
in diesem bewegen schillat der dann und dadurch erkennt dein dein Tennant gegenüber dann halt ok der ist echt jetzt aber,
relativ simpel natürlich kannst du sowas nicht entsprechenden Aufwand,
live Rändern des des des teilten sich bewegender Ausweis ein bisschen pizza-plaza die Technik die Videotechnik ist altum und um so etwas zu tun.
Aber klar das ist ein
nennen Verfahren was zur Anwendung kommt wenn du ein Konto eröffnen ist oder sonstiges ja wo wir das Thema Geldwäsche hinten dran hängen haben und unten entsprechende,
denke ich auch wichtige Faktoren die da irgendwie eine Rolle spielen das jetzt für ein einfaches Forum zu zu verlangen.
Ist ihm im Prinzip der der Nuklearschlag weil das bedeutet es wird jetzt einfach niemand mehr machen einfach das rechtliche Risiko kann sich ja niemand leisten,
auch dieses bei Zweifel musst du testen prüfen pflegen und so das geht ja alles nicht
alles nicht möglich und selbst wenn das jetzt umsetzbar wäre und am Ende passiert ist es halt wirklich ein ganz ganz fürchterliche Angriff auf die Meinungsfreiheit.
Und zumal du dir natürlich vorstellen kannst wie jetzt so eine Regierung wie sie in Österreich gerade dann ist dran ist wie sieht die sie von dieser Möglichkeit Gebrauch.
Im es ist ein ein gewisser Weise wirklich ein Angriff auf der Button vorn auf demokratischen Austausch auf die Kritik die es an dieser Regierung ja gibt.
Aber die finde ich immer noch viel zu leise ist wenn man sich anschaut was hier,
gerade alles gemacht wird das ist jetzt nur der Netz britische Teil also in Österreich ist gerade ein zügiger Umbau unseres Staates.
Der vollzogen wird wohl wirklich an ganz vielen Strukturen gerüttelt wird und das nächste ist irgendwie der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk und
es wird dann auch noch für Zivilgesellschaft enger werden der muss Nationen werden noch mal stärker eingeschränkt
werden also ich gehe davon aus dass da man jetzt wo man irgendwie mal die Arbeitslosen die Sozialhilfeempfänger und die Flüchtlinge einigermaßen Tour hat und bei der Flüchtlinge wird natürlich noch viel schlimmer aber das sind dann auch so symbolgeschichten,
heute eben also elplan ReiseCenter hat Ausreise.
Da will man halt einfach im Sinne der message Controller eine ganz wichtige doctrine dieser Regierung verhindern dass es überhaupt noch.
Den Raum für diese Debatten gibt und deswegen ist dieses Gesetz so exemplarisch für das was gerade in Österreich passiert und wieso man auch,
hier über Netzpolitik hinaus ganz entschieden dem entgegentreten muss aber trotzdem noch ganz kurz sagen soll wieso das auch nett politisch,
idiotisch ist weil identitäts Ausstellung und Beglaubigung ist eine staatliche hoheitsaufgabe,
das ist nicht dass wir dass wir an Telekom Konzerne oder irgendwelche Leute hinter Webcams auslagern sollten und
natürlich wäre es denkbar dann sowas wie einen Identitätsausweis auch mit einer,
mit einem dezentralen System auszustatten mit also ich glaube das muss ich solche Modelle zum das anschauen muss die haben immer natürlich auch wieder Security mäßig und Risiko aber da mit asymmetrischer Verschlüsselung vielleicht
etwas.
Ich glaube da verbrennst du dich gerade so ein bisschen die die Beglaubigung der Identität.
Das ist die hoheitsaufgabe ja einen Ausweis passt oder sonstiges herauszugeben die was nicht die hoheitsaufgabe ist ist die Prüfung dieser Idee.
Das ist natürlich eine eine Dienstleistung die andere für dich erbringen können.
Könnte man dieses ausstellen von Identität nicht aber irgendwie so digital abbilden das ist das ist ein Interface gibt wo ich selber die Kontrolle darüber habe an wem ich meine Identität rausgehe und deine Beglaubigung nicht bedeutet der hat meinen Namen.
Das ist schon das gibt's natürlich da gibt's auch Diskussion darüber gibt Überlegungen darüber jetzt auch technische Forschung zu aber was hier verlangt wird
ist ja und das da würde ich auch glaube ich gar nicht mich in irgendwelche auf ihr welche Diskussionen einlassen Anonymität im Internet pseudonymität im Internet,
muss sichergestellt sein ist kein Problem es ist einfach kein Problem so es gibt ein paar.
Fälle von okay Menschen beleidigen andere strafrechtlich relevant ja das passiert das ist ein Fakt.
Und dann gibt es für die Menschen keine Möglichkeit dieser diese wenigen Menschen keine Möglichkeit dieser Opfer habhaft zu werden dieser Täter.
Tschuldigung für die betroffenen Personen keine Möglichkeit diesen.
Dieser Täter Harvard zu werden das ist richtig das ist ein Problem das gefällt aber dann bitte in den Bereich der Strafverfolgung diese Fälle sind verhältnismäßig wenige was sie nicht.
Weniger schlimm macht aber das wenn das Internet als diskursraum Stil.
Dann hat das.
Zunächst einmal nur einen entscheiden Effekt und das ist das die Hoheit über den Diskurs wieder in die Hände der Regierung fällt.
Ja das ist genau das was selbst wenn man jetzt hier aus aus rechter Hardcore was weiß ich AFD blaue Partei Spinner Partei oder sonst was argumentieren möchte.
Das ist etwas zumindest jetzt in Deutschland wo wir noch nicht irgendwie so einen Sebastian Kurz.
Haben und eine Regierungskoalition mit den Faschisten,
das ist das was hier die AFD die ganze Zeit sagte sind die gleichgeschaltete Systempresse ne die Systemmedien und so weiter das ist genau das was ihr das ist der Weg dorthin was ihr nicht wollt,
ja da muss sich gegen der muss sich gegen gewendet werden.
Und zwar auch damit ihr euren AFD Dünnpfiff immer noch unter jedem Beitrag schreiben können wenn ihr sagt wenn aus Spiegel Online über Flüchtlinge geschrieben wird und,
entsprechend die zu zur Schonung der Foren Administratoren und der der allgemeinen Nerven gesagt wird unter diesen.
Artikel keine Diskussion dann empfindet ihr das als eine Einschränkung als ein Problem,
und genau das ist dann über also wenn ihr sagt was weiß ich ich möchte das wird man ja wohl noch sagen dürfen.
Dann ist das genau der Punkt was dann nicht mehr so sein wird denn auch lieber Rechte denk dran je wann kommen wir linksgrünversifft and wieder.
Und dann sind wir an der Macht und dann könnten wir euch jagen wie es der wie heißt der Gauleiter da in Deutschland schon gefordert hat ja also vorsicht mit dem was ihr euch da wünscht,
denk dran wenn das in unsere Hände fällt dann steht ihr als erstes an der Wand und genauso müsste muss man über diese Diskurse nachdenken genau sowas von dabei
denken über diese Diskurs Räume und deswegen ist das egal welcher politischen Coleman ist ein nicht akzeptabler,
Zahn.
Ganz kurz nur das SE kurz angesprochen also das Gesetz.
Delikten wo Daten bei Polizei Gericht eingeschalten ist da kannst du auf diese Daten zugreifen dann muss der Forenbetreiber sie herausgeben aber eben auch bei Algen
zivilrechtlichen Delikten eben über Nachrede Beleidigung oder Verletzung der Ehre und an der Stelle GZA mit zu bedenken dass hier nicht nur der Name sondern auch,
von dem Forenbetreiber herausgegeben wird was ein enormer chilling effect ist für,
Frauen die sich zu Feminismus Themen äußern zu Antipasti vielleicht AA,
Nazis sagen okay das hier ist keine Meinung von dir am überall da wo ich gab aufmachen kann das für mich gerade meiner Ehre beleidigt habe ich daraufhin die Privatadresse dieser Person und da das heißt hier
geht's dann von Hass im Netz auf einmal zu realer Gewalt die vielleicht das Konsequenz von diesem Gesetz und droht,
an das ganze ist im Moment.
Entwurf der am 1. September 2020 in Kraft treten soll das ist Begutachtung läuft aber noch bis zum 23.Mai wir werden wieder in der Stellungnahme
herausgeben und was spannend ist ist dass dieses Gesetz a an die EU Kommission
gemeldet werden muss und es 3 Monate Begutachtung gibt wo andere EU-Staaten ihre Meinung dazu sagen kann,
könnte sein dass es da noch internationale Debatten dazu gibt Österreich ist glaube ich hier
als erste mit so einer schlechten Idee nach vorne gebracht ich hoffe dass es da auch fertig von der Kommission oder andere Mitgliedstaaten gibt dem Vernehmen nach gibt es aber auch schon ein.
Land das.
Plant ein ähnliches Gesetz auf den Weg zu bringen und wie könnte es anders sein wer ist in letzter Zeit netzpolitische persönlich in jederlei Hinsicht immer auf der,
falschen Seite
Frankreich natürlich wieder am und und scheinbar gerüchteweise zumindest aus aber an der Stelle von recht glaubwürdige Seite nicht glaubwürdig an Frankreich ähnliche Gesetze auch und.
Wir hoffen aber eben auch kritische Stimmen und das war's aber jetzt auch mal irgendwie dazu ich glaube.
Ich will da nur ich will nur kurz Zeit noch kurz was sagen bevor jetzt nachher wieder irgendjemand meinte ich will jemanden an die Wand stellen das war ein Scherz und II. Den will ich trotzdem noch mal betonen weil mir das
insgesamt in diesem in den Diskussionen immer wieder weil ich das feststelle weil mir das auf.
Es ist natürlich ein Mißstand wenn Menschen.
Wie öffentlich beleidigt werden oder auch privat beleidigt werden belästigt werden und dies aus dem Schutze der Anonymität passiert es ist in keiner Form gutzuheißen dass das so ist.
Und ich möchte mich auch nicht in die Ecke drängen lassen dass ich das gutheißen würde nun ist es aber so,
ist irgendwie auch das Wesen der Politik dass du jeden einen Missstand den du in den Griff bekommen möchtest immer nur bis zu einem gewissen Rahmen in den Griff bekommen wirst ohne.
Die im Prinzip den nächsten Missstand ins Haus zu holen und das ist im im Einzelfall eben sehr sehr tragisch ich bin ja auch in in einigen Situationen was dass ich.
Opfer die Personen von Straftaten gewesen und hatte auch nicht den Genuss.
Da darauf hin zu führen dass die Täter einer Strafe laut StGB zugeführt wurden.
Das ist hart und.
Gleichzeitig muss ich für mich selber denn eben auch wahrnehmen ja es gibt eben die Grenzen der Strafverfolgung und wäre die Welt eine solche.
In der mir hier in der jetzt dieses dieses rechtsstaatliche Verfahren.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht gescheitert wäre dann wäre es auf jeden Fall eine schlechtere Welt und so ist es eben nur eine schlechte.
Situation in meinem Leben die ich auch nicht gut finde ja und dann wäre ich auch zu knacken habe aber.
Dieses balancieren von Rechten und Schäden.
Ist das Wesen der Politik und jede fundamentale und radikale Lösung führt da eben zu weiteren Schäden in diesem Fall eben einem.
Der uns allen nicht recht sein kann und.
Das ist in diesem Fall so sowieso so gut zu sehen und wir werden jetzt natürlich mit den Fällen konfrontiert werden schau dir an das kann ich dir jetzt schon sagen dann geht's halt um wird und Minderheiten gehen die verfolgt werden um natürlich den.
Liberalen linksgrünversifft in den Wind aus den Segeln zu nehmen im Kampf gegen diese Argumentation.
Er ging diese Gesetzgebung und wird natürlich dann wird ganz klar irgendwie Frauen die belästigt werden Andy herhalten als Beispiele.
Andere Minderheiten die Diskriminierung Verfolgung Beschimpfungen ausgesetzt werden werden dann herhalten müssen im Prinzip für einen einen,
sein an für einen Angriff auf die Meinungsfreiheit insgesamt für eine radikale Erleichterung der Kontrolle.
Von von Dissidenten in diesem Land und das ist letztendlich Schaden für die Freiheit insgesamt und deswegen.
Sind wir ja auch an dem Punkt und sind wir ja auf der Position zu sagen.
Das ist eben der saure Apfel in die wir beißen müssen dass wir dieses Land im Rahmen unserer Wahrnehmung voll haben also das Deutschland-Österreich voll haben von irgendwelchen.
Rechtsradikalen faschistischen handbürsten die sich unqualifiziert zur politischen Themen das wird man doch noch einmal sagen dürfen ja nur dass ihr das noch sagen dürft.
Da steht wenn wir niemals in Frage stellen dass ihr den Stoß in die Welt Posaunen dürft werden wir niemals in Frage stellen und auch dass ihr das aus.
Aus einer Position der Anonymität tun dürfen.
Ich würde deine Nummer zwei radikaler Reposition zusehen erstens ich denke.
Austausch der Ideen muss es immer egal sein von wem die Idee kommt.
Das muss einfach vollkommen keine Rolle spielen insofern deine Idee kann noch so scheiße sein es ist irrelevant sehr wer sie sagt die Idee muss bewertet werden das gibt eben auch.
Viele Jahre später so was wie wenn Julian ist heute eine Idee äußert muss diese Idee unabhängig davon bewertet werden welche Vorwürfe ist gegen gegen gegen ihn gibt und was er als Charakter ist
genau das versuchen wir in loco Netflix. Zweitens das ist jetzt da werden sich einige Leute ärgern.
Es gibt immer einen der beleidigen will.
Und eine sich beleidigen lässt und für mich ist als jemand der natürlich auch das ein oder andere mal eine Nachricht von irgendjemanden aus der Anonymität bekommt.
Also ich bewerte halt die Idee und die Äußerungen ja und da gibt's genug Leute mit hohem Ruf die ich namentlich kenne die einfach nur Stuss von sich geben.
Oder auch Leute mit sinkendem Ruf die irgendwelchen Stuss von sich geben und genug Leute die anonym oder nicht anonym sind oder pseudonym haben das aber öffentlich bekannt sind die irgendwelchen Stuss sagen.
Der vielleicht auch für mich beleidigend sein könnten den ich dann eben nicht so sehe.
Und das ist natürlich das heißt nicht dass das gut ist dass sie das tun.
Aber es ist wichtig dass sie es können und nur so ist eben auch eine eine kompetente Austausch in diesem Internet überhaupt möglich wenn wir.
Die Idee bewerten wenn wir im Prinzip darauf scheißen können von wem sie kommt.
Und wenn wir über ein paar Sachen auch drüber stehen das ist notwendige Kompetenz die in der Gesellschaft an sehr vielen Stellen fehlt.
Also ganz kurz nur data
Pizza wir sind mit dem gesetzt werden wir natürlich niemals das Problem lösen dass Leute aus der Anonymität angefeindet werden du kannst natürlich weiterhin über Burger E-Mail-Adresse oder sonstigen Kanälen Leute,
beleidigen.
Dazu wird mich das Problem nicht gelöst.
Und du hast halt einfach die Diskurs Räume die unheimlich wichtig sind für eine Demokratie die der Ort sind wo.
Meinung sichtbar wird wo Meinung sich nicht nur Bilder sondern wo sie auch abgelesen werden kann wie oft bin ich schon irgendwie in dem Standard Kommentaren.
Drüber gescrollt abgelesen damit ich ein Gefühl dafür bekomme,
wie Themen verstanden werden was ich leider dazu denken in welche Richtung das gerade geht das ist ein wichtiger Gradmesser der.
Umfragen kosten viel Geld die werden punktuell gemacht sondern die sich leisten können das ist so eine line ein sehr subjektiver aber trotzdem ein Einblick auf.
Diesen Leuten der Mund gewachsen ist ja was ist nicht immer schön aber das ist der Spiegel.
Den das Internet der Gesellschaft vorhält und es ist nicht immer das Internet wieso wir das nicht.
Höfen was wir da sehen manchmal ist es auch die Gesellschaft in der wir leben und.
Insofern ist es gerade wieder gesagt dass der das wird man doch wohl noch sagen kann mit so einem Gesetz ändern wird grundlegend die Struktur dieser Diskurs raten.
Und die Eintrittspforte,
für Menschen sich an dieser Debatte zu beteiligen und es werden eben nicht die Leute sein die immer sich im Recht fühlen und das wird man schon noch sagen dürfen die werden sich durch eine Klarnamenpflicht,
abhalten lassen tun wir in den letzten Jahren nicht aber ich glaube es gibt ganz viele Menschen die in unserer Gesellschaft was wichtiges beizutragen hätten und haben.
Die.
Inam chilling effect von so einer Maßnahme sich zurück drängen lassen und weniger auf die Gegenrede üben weniger office in Kauf nehmen auch,
Konsequenzen am Leben zu haben und Zeit die nur theoretisch aber da da da muss man drauf schauen.
Hans Söllner zitiere ich in letzter Zeit öfter von dem stammt glaube ich so diese Feststellungen Freiheit muss weh tun.
Da ist viel dran das habe ich über die Jahre gelernt was aber dennoch für schlechte Nachrichten.
Eine gute Nachricht gute Nacht aber ganz ganz kurz nur weil wir uns beide.
Eingelöst haben wir haben eine auf die EU-Ebene gesagt letztes Plenum dieses Europaparlaments und es ist an whistleblowerschutz dort
Gesetz geworden also ich habe mir die Details wirklich nicht angeschaut ich glaube es ist eine Richtlinie die eben gewisse Mindeststandards für
den Schutz von Whistleblowern in Europa fest schreibt und ich glaube da hat sich irgendwie auch noch mal,
Deutschland nicht durchgesetzt damit dass der ganze Mission versteckt dass dieser.
Ja Deutschland heute.
Wenn du vorher intern probiert hast dass du mit diesem diesen an Würfen sozusagen internen schon mal irgendwie gefragt ist das nicht scheiße was hier läuft.
Ja Deutschland wollte sie wollte sagen sie du musst dich erst innerhalb deines Unternehmens
Elke gemeldet haben bevor du straffrei als Whistleblower an die Öffentlichkeit gehen kannst hätte ich echt scheiße wenn das Unternehmen hat genau weiß wer es war das konnte sich nicht durchsetzen und in diesen neuen,
Gesetz des EU-Parlaments werden Whistleblower gegen solche Racheakte der betroffenen Parteien geschützt.
Es soll sichere sichere Meldestellen innerhalb des EU Gesetzes daneben geben und damit haben wir jetzt eine EU-weite Whistleblower.
Schutz.
Situation die von den Whistleblower Anliegern und leaking Plattformen und Transparenz Aktivisten unseres Vertrauens sehr positiv bewertet wird und,
um die sendung jetzt kurz zu halten haben wir uns dann noch nicht spezifisch tiefer eingelesen sondern geben das jetzt einfach mal wieder das dass es positiv zu.
Sehen ist das Deutschland hier ist man nicht geschafft hat sich mit seiner Scheiße durch.
Wir bleiben bei der EU Vorratsdatenspeicherung kommt wieder
aber es soll einen neuen Anlauf geben eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung auf EU Ebene einzuführen und du hast voll gesagt ich soll Verantwortung für die österreichische Regierung
übernehmen was ich hiermit tue auf das Verlangen von Österreich ist dieser neue Anlauf bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung zustande gekommen noch im Dezember letzten Jahres unter der österreichischen Ratspräsidentschaft
hat man da angefangen zu sticheln und eben jetzt
gibt es auch als hättet alliierte Aussagen der verschiedenen Mitgliedstaaten und im Rat wird eben diskutiert in der sogenannten
habe jetzt Arbeitsgruppe wenn es interessiert wie man eben eine neue Vorratsdatenspeicherung machen könnte das kannst du soll eine rechtskonforme Vorratsdatenspeicherung sein was
mich ist aber das ist immer schön wenn man das drauf schreibt.
Ich finde das ja super wenn die sich bei ihren Gesetzen überlegen dass sie jetzt mal einen rechtskonformes Gesetz erlassen wollt immerhin.
Also das ist aber nicht wie das nicht gesundes Müsli an es ist auf jeden Fall Annan versuch jetzt wieder der aber fertig ist leider nicht,
ganz dumm ist die war nämlich das Thema mit der eprivacy,
Ordnung junktimieren und Zusammenziehen die eprivacy-verordnung ist ein ganz wichtiges Datenschutzgesetz da schon über viele Jahre jetzt im werden ist wo aber den Rat das Gesetz festhängt,
unter den Mitgliedstaaten keine Einigung gibt auch hier hat Österreich in seiner Ratspräsidentschaft das ganze schön verschleppt sodass die rumänische aktuelle Ratspräsidentschaft jetzt erst irgendwie dazu kommt das werde ich zu verhandeln und hier,
diesmal weiter auf der Bremse also wird man beobachten jetzt wo das Parlament sozusagen out of session ist und erst im.
Juli September wieder zu arbeiten beginnt macht der Rat natürlich weiter und kümmert sich um solche Themen zurück nach Österreich
wir haben eine ganz kurze Ankündigungen nur für die nächsten Wochen die schwarzen schreien das ist ein neues Transparenzregister geben wird es hört sich im ersten Moment super an
mehr Transparenz geil ja
was aber mit ihrem Transparenzregister gemeint ist das nicht der Star transparente wird sondern die Bevölkerung und zwar in einer großen Datenbank sollen
alle Sozialleistungen von allen armen Menschen dieses Landes gesammelt werden was natürlich schon auch wieder der nächste Schritt
auf die Kürzung dieser Sozialleistungen ist es gibt auch,
ernst gemeinten Vorschlag dass Menschen die Mindestsicherung also Sozialhilfe empfangen wenn die Spenden bekommen sollen diese Spenden ihnen von der Sozialhilfe abgezogen,
am
Sparda-hessen auch irgendwie das Parteispenden von der Partei Förderung abgezogen werden und dass diese Regierung irgendwie sich endlich schämt.
Das sind so keine so schlechte Idee.
Bin ich auch
auf jeden Fall dass das da gibt noch keine Gesetzesvorschlag aber dem Vernehmen nach wird der den nächsten Wochen kommen und uns beschäftigen letztes Thema
und wieder eines aus Österreicher der Kurzmeldung ist dank der wunderbaren Barbara Wimmer eine Journalistin die noch von the one and only Erich Möchel ausgebildet und wurde die hat in Erfahrung gebracht dass Österreich Softair gekauft hat
österreich hat eine Software zur Gesichtserkennung mit öffentlichen Kameras gekauft und es gibt irgendwie so unterschiedliche Meinungen
die offizielle Geschichte ist
dass wir jetzt nur der Softair gekauft haben wenn er sozusagen einen mag Socken beim Verhandeln also du hast irgendwie ein Bild von dem Bankräuber und dann hast du eine Datenbank mit den bekannten Verbrechern und eine Software die.
Gesichter abgleicht ist offiziell das was sie jetzt gekauft haben und nicht mehr ich glaube so nicht ganz weil in dem,
letztes Jahr 2018 beschlossen überwachungspaket ist nämlich eine Echtzeit
Übertragung von einem Videoüberwachungen ans Innenministerium legalisiert worden in Österreich und zwar auf Basis des sich jetzt Polizeigesetzes nicht um konkrete Straftaten aufzuklären sondern die präventive Gefahrenabwehr ist hier,
die Rechtsgrundlage das heißt doch ohne Verdacht will man sozusagen in den großen Video Feeds nach,
versuchen und Gefahren hermessence Gesichter und deswegen ist durchaus auch am zu Sorge aufgerufen das vielleicht diese diese neue Software vielleicht auch hierfür eingesetzt wird um diese
Videoaufzeichnungen von Flughäfen von Tankstellen eben auch nach.
Betanken Gefährtinnen und Gefährdung Zurich suchen wohlgemerkt Gefährder sind Menschen die noch nicht Einsatz
ja also das nur kurz am Rande weil es uns eben auch diese Woche beschäftigt war eine lange Woche.
Arm und an damit kommen wir auch eigentlich so eher zu den zu den Service heraus Mainz und zwar das ist jetzt nur für Menschen in Österreich es ist ja eine EU-Wahl am 25 26 Mai.
Wie habt ihr zwei Tage Zeit wir haben nur ein.
Nur das Sonntag oder der ich weiß noch nicht welcher ob das.
Bitte ich habe damit ich habe da tatsächlich die der also in Deutschland ist das der 26 Arbeit die EU-Wahl geht tatsächlich vom 23 bisschen 26.
Ja ich glaube das bei manchen Sendern.
In unterschiedlichen Ländern die haben da unterschiedliche Regeln und EMDR Baba in Österreich muss man Wahlkarten geworden oder was.
Genau also ist sie nämlich normalerweise so dass in Österreich oder ganz viele Leute verwenden Fahrkarten weil sie vielleicht nicht zu Hause sind oder zu ihrem Wahllokal nicht hingehen wollen und diesen Sonntag weiß ich.
Draußen sind und normalerweise informiert das Innenministerium per Post über die Möglichkeit Fahrkarten zu beantragen und informiert auch wie das geht,
nur dieses Mal zum ersten Mal hat das Innenministerium unter Herbert Kickl von der
FPÖ darauf verzichtet die Leute brauchst du informieren dass sie ja Wahlkarten beantragen könnten historisch gesehen sind Wahlkarten besonders hilfreich für linke Parteien insofern,
bitte man wenn man ein Schelm ist unterstellen dass er vielleicht die Briefkarten velati eher links sind vielleicht.
Achso weil die ganzen weil die Warum für die Linken weil die salonkommunisten alle in der Toskana leben oder was.
Genau also da ist ja wenn du mit der wenn du da irgendwie deine drittwohnsitz hast oder Escort was oder vielleicht am Sonntag noch hangover,
dann wäre es ja vielleicht ganz toll wenn du per Brief schon vorher gewählt hättest und damit die Leute das mitbekommen geben wir jetzt hier noch mal
den Linken die schon aus wenn ihr in Österreich wahlberechtigt hat für die Europawahl könnt ihr da noch bis zum 22.Mai eure Wahlkarte beantragen
und zuletzt haben wir,
Stellenausschreibungen von befreundeten Organisationen zu verlautbaren Max Schrems sucht in seiner NGO non of your business neu,
einen Single oder einen Dieter protection layer,
einen Lidl Hintern wer sich da angesprochen fühlt und juristisch ausgebildet ist möge sich bewerben wir verlinken und edry European that alright sucht nach einem intramex Akademie,
Acta weil unsere jetzige Geschäftsführerin bei e3a auf mit heute die tief geht die ist schwanger und da wird für ein halbes Jahr ein,
Ersatz gesucht in dieser Zeit.
Arm und das ist dir schon dieses Jahr deswegen wer sich da berufen fühlt in einer der wichtigsten Organisationen in Europa mal als
guter Administrator Administrator in auszuhelfen können sich dort bewerben.
Vorsicht Administrator wird in unseren in unserer höher.
Dadadadadadada
Verwalter also ein Mensch der einfach nur den Laden am Laufen hält es ist ein gutes Team ist es jetzt nicht so dass man irgendwie man übernimmt die Geschäftsführer das exakte Traktor aber es ist eben nur für die Zeit wo das
bibi hat gerade frisch da ist und deswegen nur einer Interims Stelle.
Ja und mehr mehr Jobs haben wir gerade nicht.
BR.de EMI Center sucht gerade mal nicht.
Wir sind sehr happy mit unserem Team,
wir uns was Gutes tun will kann Fördermitglied werden wir haben coole T-Shirts die wir gerade verschickt haben an die Fördermitglieder die Filmes kriegen auch bei uns irgendwie coole USB Sticks und so zeigt das heißt.
Französisch auch als als danke schön dafür.
Die Filme sind die Fördermitglieder.
Genau,
das habe ich von der digitalen Gesellschaft ich finde ihn sehr passend er doch liebevoll gemein und wer den Newsletter noch nicht so schreibt hat dann hört ihr vielleicht sehr vorbei ja wenn man Logbuch net.
Gratis total da hat man dann regelmäßige EU und vielleicht doch Österreich Update den das interessiert.
Wir haben ja auch vor gar nicht allzu langer Zeit Anfang dieses Jahres in der EM p281 oder sowas war das glaube ich über die verschiedenen Spendenmöglichkeiten gesprochen.
Heidi es gibt ich habe da mal so einen Überblick gegeben von netzpolitik.org über Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte über digitale Gesellschaft über epicenter works die Spenden zu werden,
Handy aus und Thomas und ich haben da gestern Abend noch mal so ein bisschen drüber gesprochen die sind im Prinzip.
Alle an der fandet ja wenn man das vergleicht mit animals eine Summe die mir völlig unklar war du hast erwähnt die Electronic Frontier Foundation also die US Bürgerrechtsorganisation im digitalen Bereich
wie wir wissen gegründet von.
Gary Barlow und Gilmore die aber doch schon sehr viel länger besteht als jetzt in wie diese diese deutschen Organisation die haben einen funding von,
sich Millionen US-Dollar im Jahr.
Wie heißt die Zahl die ich im Kopf habe also es gibt da natürlich Transparenz.
Also das Spannende ist dass die überhaupt mehr als eine Millionen haben.
Ja weit weit weit.
Was aber für die europäischen Indios eben eine ihre Menge ist weil wir uns ist keine europäische NGO im digitalen Bürgerrechts Bereich eingefallen die über 1000000 hätte.
Wenn man könnte da jetzt wenn man Amnesty mit rein nimmt.
Privacy international vielleicht noch also die wirklich global agierenden aber in Europa 17. Organisationen aber die Didi der
die Kennzahl die ich da immer Herr anziehe ist alle Mitgliedsorganisationen von Idris müssen ein Prozent ihres Budgets dass sie für das ist sozusagen der Teil ihrer Organisation der sich um europäische Netzpolitik kümmert,
davon ein Prozent ist der Mitgliedsbeitrag Hanni drin und das erlaubt dir ein bisschen hoch zu rechnen und da kommst du Daumen mal Pi auf ein Gesamtvolumen der europäischen Netzpolitik
für alle 28 Länder in allen 24 Sprachen alle NGOs zusammen von fünf bis sechs Millionen.
So und das sollte uns allen zu denken geben.
Und deswegen gerne mal darüber nachdenken welche der netzpolitische aktiven Organisationen denn den Track Record hat den ihr.
Unterstützen möchtet,
wir haben auch gestern sehr viel darüber gesprochen was eben die der Unterschied zwischen bezahlten Aktivismus und dem unbezahlten ist wie ihr
sicherlich wisst bin ich da Eisenhardt mit dem Chaos Computer Club und auch mit letzten logbuch-netzpolitik
auf der unbezahlten oder maximal eben für lnp mal die eine oder andere freundliche Spende Seite Thomas
offene professionalisierten Zweig mit.
Epicenter works und jetzt auch übrigens gratulation das aber ehrenamtlich bei edry.
Im Vorstand herzlichen Glückwunsch das freut mich sehr und man kann das natürlich am.
An der Professionalität der Arbeit an der Kontinuität der Arbeit und an der Qualität der Arbeit eben auch sehen was das eben bedeutet wenn sich jemand wie Thomas bei epicenter eben,
das zum zur Hauptaufgabe macht während eben der Chaos Computer Club unabhängig.
Spezifisch die Entscheidung getroffen hat nicht in den bezahlten Aktivismus zu verfallen wir haben da denke ich auch.
Die negativen Beispiele sehr nah vor Augen
wo man sieht was das eben auch für ein Organisation bedeuten kann wenn sie sich irgendwie wenn dass sich verselbständigt wenn die die Spenden des Spenden eintreiben irgendwann zum Selbstzweck wird und die Organisation daneben
im Prinzip um ihrer selbst er halt nur noch agiert und nicht mehr
um der Inhalte Willen also das ist auch eine eine Sorge die wir eben vor Augen haben und da muss man dann eben schauen wie man.
Ja welche Organisation förder förderungswürdig ist und die Auswahl ist ist groß,
und die sind alle an der Fahne du kannst eigentlich kaum einer Organisation im Netz politischen Bereich.
Geld geben was die nicht sinnvoll einsetzen würde na wo wurde wohnt woran es ihr nicht mangeln würde.
Also ganz praktisch gesprochen als du mit Multiplex campane die wir gemacht haben
weil nur mit Telefonrechnung und insgesamt wir haben bei uns mal zusammengerechnet und um die 35000 € die wir da
in den Miesen gegangen sind und wir haben auch keine Förderung dafür bekommen weil die Zeit nicht da war irgendwie Anträge zu schreiben sondern hat einfach wirklich aus den Spendengeldern die wir schon hatten mal in Vorleistung gegangen.
Auf den aus dem Prinzip aus den Rücklagen quasi also das Geld war ja da ich habe jetzt keinen keinen Kredit auf.
Wir haben wir haben doch türlich die Reserven damit wir immer so annähernd bis zum Jahr kommen also dieses Jahr ist es noch nicht das sind wir nicht ausfinanziert
müssen im Weber nicht mehr reinkommen im September habe ich anfangen heute rauszuwerfen aber wenn du so eine Option hast die Abstimmung passiert jetzt du musst du jetzt agieren und wenn du dann noch irgendwie wartest bist ja irgendwann Fördergeber dann auch sagt ja ja und ich werde die Rechnung übernehmen bist du zu spät,
Antennenfernsehen Spendengelder auch der Freiheitsgrad den du hast schnell zu reagieren und das zu tun was getan werden muss und wir hoffen halt einfach immer dass wir im Nachhinein den Wohlwollen bekommen,
und und sowie der Refinanzierung gerade also bei der askvoll vergeben ist dein voller la uns und ich denke mir halt gerade auch bei so welcome pannensicher hätten wir gewonnen wäre das alles kein Thema hier haben 4:30 Uhr.
Stimmen gefehlt und deswegen ja aber trotzdem wir werden.
Wie siehst du wie siehst du das denn übrigens ganz ehrlich mal kurz Elisabeth Campania wenn ihr gewonnen hätte wäre das Ding wahrscheinlich längst wieder refinanziert muss man Aussehen so ein bisschen also der.
Wir haben noch dazu in der Datenschutzbestimmungen drinne gehabt wenn wir gewinnen.
Erlauben wir uns dass wir den Satz schreiben was er tausende Leute waren die über uns telefoniert haben regelmäßig das wird den einmalig eine sms schicken mit einem Spendenaufruf.
Dazu kam natürlich nicht aber wenn ich gewonnen haben aber ich habe externer Datenschutz policy reingeschrieben wenn wir gewinnen dann,
schick mir einmal kurz SMS Spam raus mit übrigens wenn du es cool fandest dass du uns verwenden konntest dann ist hier irgendwie der Link um uns vielleicht die Telefonrechnung zu zahlen wir haben das natürlich nicht gemacht weil wir.
Gewonnen haben aber im Grunde ist immer noch so meine Aufführung dass ich das über die lange Sicht refinanziert und,
eigentlicher gebraucht würde ist dass wir solche Spende solche solche Anrufe Tools nicht immer nur dann bauen wenn die sie jetzt gerade brauchen sondern.
Es geht ja auch darum das zu haben.
Ja wenn du sowas hat wirklich wieder verwendbar hättest und dass du halt nicht irgendwie wie wir hoffen Wecker brauchst die gerade für dich verfügbar sind um sowas zu bauen,
ich wollte dir nur noch mal an ich auf deinen vorherigen Punkt zurückkommen es ist,
beides wichtig sowohl ehrenamtliche Arbeit wie bezahlter Arbeit sind unterschiedliche Schwerpunkte die du hast ich habe ja selber erst 2014 den Sprung gemacht von es ist ein Hobby nee es ist mein Beruf von meiner Berufung und
ich find's immer extrem wichtig dass diese zwei Aspekte sich auch gegenseitig bestärken und befruchten und ich bin noch stolz dass wir bei E3
beide Arten von Organisationen drinnen haben als stimmberechtigte Mitglieder damit du einfach auch immer beide Zugänge auf die Themen präsent hast.
Auf jeden Fall also ich denke ich will da gar nicht ich will nur würdigen dass es diese Ansätze gibt die ergänzen sich alle gegenseitig ist wäre nicht gut zu sagen man was dass ich verlagert sich nur auf eine Organisation die Wirtin fällt ein bisschen zu groß
ich möchte wollte eigentlich nur auf den Missstand aufmerksam machen den im Prinzip alle diese Organisationen haben und dass ihr da gerne,
Liebe hören und höre die Organisation eurer Wahl mit dem Ansatz den sie verfolgt unterstützen könnt,
achtet einfach auf den Track Record genauso wie es der digitalnomaden macht der sagt geht der auch man wählt nicht aufgrund der Wahlversprechen sondern.
Der bisherigen Erfolge und das will ich ihn sehr komfortablen sehr sehr charmanten sehr sinnvollen Ansatz da natürlich auch ein bisschen auf die
Meriten und die Aktivitäten der letzten Jahre zu schauen wo es mein Geld gut angelegt wenn du nichts anderes geht hier.
Ist eine Investition in Grundrechte Investition in die Zukunft eurer auch eigene Zukunft die uber,
Kinder und was nicht alles gibt so Thomas du wolltest noch jemanden danken.
Ja darüber denkst du ja immer ich habe da irgendwie eine Person die Stange von der Firma rieco Druck die bei der pledge Kampagne
wirklich exzellent mitgeholfen hat eine wahnsinnig tolle kommt bei inneren ist deswegen wollte ich mich hier nur noch mal bei ihr bedanken und
Tattoo hat Angst niemanden.
Ich habe muss jetzt kurz gucken ich habe also ist stehen keine in der Liste ich bin viel auf Reise gewesen in den letzten Wochen wenn er immer ein bisschen unterwegs und denke dann wird es nächste mal eine längere Liste mit dank geben.
Wunderbar dann haben wir es.
Damit haben wir das Ende der Sendung erreicht und wünschen euch noch viel Spaß im Internet.
Tata.